police are mobilizing in Los Angeles in
Philadelphia in New York many other
cities are preparing for tomorrow's
Global day of jihad I hope everybody is
safe we talked a bit about it on the
members only show there are people who
are quite concerned after the former
leader and a current member of Hamas
called for Muslims around the world to
engage in Jihad to show Israel and the
us up or something like that and uh
there's now serious concerns about
security issues while we are concerned
there are many news outlets saying these
are just protests they're just they're
calling for protests that's it K we'll
see stay safe stay safe everybody at the
same time the protests we are seeing
from far leftist at various universities
they're chanting there is only one
solution I kid you not that's what
they're chanting uh uh the full chant is
there is one there's only one solution
into F Revolution but for what reason
would they chant one solution because
you know people understand what that
what that means and refers to so we're
going to talk about that and a bunch
more before we do my friends head over
to cast brew.com and buy yourself some
cast brew coffee if you want to support
the show you can go to cast Brew buy
coffee and not only are you helping us
perform the jobs that we do you are
going to get the best cup of coffee
you've ever had my personal favorite is
appalachin kns close second is rise with
Roberto Jr but I got to be honest rise
with Roberto Jr sells the best we also
have Mr Bokus pumpkin spice experience
which is very good stand to your grounds
a medium roast we've got whole bean
we've got ground we got K Cups man it's
all coming along you can join the casar
coffee Club if you want to get a couple
bags every month get to it and then
we're going to have our Halloween rise
with Roberto Jr coming up soon also head
over to
timcast.net to us so smash the like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends joining us
tonight to talk about this and a whole
lot more is Blair white you had me on a
very non-controversial week right the
most controversial right right got a lot
to talk about who are you what do you do
oh yeah Blair white been here a few
times but always excited to be back
YouTuber uh I guess influencer TM I do a
lot on the internet so well right on
thanks for hanging out yep we got Brett
daic what is going on guys yes my name
is Brett dvic I am the host one of the
hosts of Pop Culture crisis Monday
through Friday 3 p.m. Eastern Standard
Time right here on YouTube happy to be
here and I'm Ian cross and hello
everyone last night after the show a
little late at night 12 o'clock or so I
decided to go live on Twitter on X and
did a a space and about God and I
realized at some point like it's less
about me telling people I just want to
hear what you think it is so I'm going
to do that again tonight it's going to
be later just keep an eye on my Twitter
and I want to hear from you and and and
see how you define this this whole
situation it was really really amazing
so thanks to everyone that came out you
mean you mean X it was all happening on
X Tim you had an xace I was on X last
night I
did when people are are in Elon musk's
rocket SpaceX they'll be having an xace
xace and SpaceX rocket for sure we just
call it
Twix uses both of them you know people
around him still say Twitter and he gets
mad you just know that happens but like
if we're going to use like like a
thumbnail that involves people talking
about stuff that happened there
confusing we use Twitter still like it's
the only time we still use Twitter right
where we got St hanging out yeah I only
like uh Twix cuz it's left right Twix
you know left Twix right Twix perect
anyways you guys can find me on Twix
surge.com let's get started all right
everybody here's the here's the big
story we have this from Los Angeles
magazine LAPD to increase patrols after
Hamas urges Global day of jihad on
Friday the 13th geez talk about just
like wow Friday the 13th come on what a
perfect alignment and I'm flying
tomorrow we have on a flight you guys
book that's right we have this from the
Philly Police Department Public Safety
alert PPD response to conflict in Israel
and Gaza in response to the ongoing
conflict the Philadelphia Police
Department is taking practive measures
to ensure the safety and security of our
communities we have increased Patrol and
religious in uh patrols around religious
institutions and all available officers
have been placed in uniform and deployed
strategically around the city to offer
reassurance visibility is a key element
of our approach blah blah blah you get
the point and then of course we have the
soft ing of the issue this one I'm sorry
this one really pissed me off this
pissed me off a lot New York Post writes
NYPD orders all cops to report in
uniform after ex Hamas Chief calls for
Global
protests going is that they call he
called for Jihad isn't that right he
said Jihad yeah Jihad is a there's
there's a violent Force involved in
Jihad to be honest I I don't want it
refers to struggle Jihad mean struggle
okay so tell maybe he's not calling for
violence then following yes he is
following the the terror attacks that we
just saw in Israel him coming out and
saying because Israel is bombing Gaza
there should be Global Jihad yo he's not
saying to wave little flags and they
were already the other day softening the
language from Terrorist on like what
right so that's already MSNBC right well
MSNBC right but it's not just MSNBC
there was a a leaked email maybe was the
telegram or something Telegraph or
something like that I don't know I don't
want to be smch a newspaper but uh so
I'm not sure but there were like leaked
messages some newspaper was like don't
call them terrorists call them gunmen oh
my God but I mean that's the same here
right it's like we've seen incidents of
our quote unquote protests that are
actually just domestic terrorism and one
of the ways they actually get it through
is by softening that definition and they
stick to it so it's terrifying you know
makes me think of when we had uh with
when Obama was in office when there was
military age men remember that instead
like when they were using the term
military age men which just means like
adults oh was so young I they've been
saying that a lot about the people that
are immigrating you illegal immigrants
they were saying it around like people
people dying overseas and they're saying
the men that died were military age men
that doesn't mean that they were
actually you know yeah 42y old farmer or
33y old teacher or something right and
we've had mostly peaceful protests now
since 2020 so exactly did you see the
protest in France and we might even get
to this I don't know if you have the
story queued up but they were prop
Palestine uh you know protests riots I
don't know protests then the government
said no it's illegal you can't do that
so now they're protesting that the
government made the protests illegal and
then stuff's getting burned you know
it's it's it's funny because this
country used to be completely unified in
their support for Israel Democrats and
Republicans and now the Democrats are in
a serious hard place because yeah the
young Progressive Democrats hate Israel
and are pro Palestine is the internet
the liberal economic order did not see
the internet coming or or maybe they had
an idea but they did not I don't think
think they understood the amount of of
understanding that would come from these
like these clandestine things that
they've been doing like the Bal for
Declaration was not public knowledge
like 5 days ago now people know that the
British set up five days ago like all of
a sudden now people start it's like
trending on Twitter balur I see people
talking about Bal for declaration it's
like the British and French setting up
isra the colony the British mandate for
Palestine after World War I They seized
it from the Arabs they they tricked the
Arabs and then they took they they
betrayed the Arabs and took it well
let's not also forget just to add to my
fear of tomorrow not that I want to
manifest anything to happen obviously
it's I've been hearing about a red
heer yeah they're they're fulfilling a
prophecy tomorrow as well not tomorrow
or it's been fulfilled and tomorrow's
like the day no no no no no no no that
that it's that on September 8th there
was reports that like the the the red
heer was born or something and so people
are trying to bring about the Messianic
era or whatever but that that's in line
with um there's also been a conspiracy I
think Alex Jones has talked about this
that there I think this was Alex Jones
there are people who are trying to make
prophecy happen uh like Revelation so
instead of looking at like these things
will happen they're looking at like we
must make these things happen which is
playing God even if you believe in the
prophecies that's so there people have
been talking about this there's concern
that uh in September there was a story
about the red heer or whatever and I
looked it up and I it's for it's from
ford.com I mean this is a i think.com
it's like a Jewish publication talking
about what it could mean and if it is
pure red heph it means they can like
purify the ground or whatever so the
fears is that tomorrow something bad
happens and then Israel people will tear
down the Alexa mosque in Jerusalem or
something like that I don't know I don't
know enough about it all I know is
there's like a whole lot of weird like
crazy religious stuff going on and
tomorrow which is Friday the 13th and
there there's an eclipse on Saturday too
right yeah the the the ring of fire
eclipse is Saturday is that true it
passes through North America yep and of
course it's the ring of fire like non-
normal Clips Ring of Fire okay great M
yeah I think the red heer is something
that someone figured out in like 1989
from when I read about this so every can
kind of we've been talking about a lot
we haven't actually figured the whole
story out red heer has to do with
something that someone read into the
Bible they saw this stuff that mentioned
red heer this is like Moses ERA this is
a while ago this is within Judaism I
don't know how much has to do with the
Apocalypse Now I don't know what else
means but a lot of read so tomorrow is
the global day of jihad on Friday the
13th and Saturday is the ring of fire
Eclipse I should not have smiled in that
thumbnail it was crazy I me title and
then I'm going to spend the day in the
emergency bunker playing balers Gate 3
and just lock the door and turn the
lights off that's smart waited out I
thought it was weird that September 11th
happened on 911 yeah I've always thought
about that actually but why though I
don't it CU it's like the emergency
number what if it happened on like 314
people would be like whoa
hi 911 emergency right people always
people always like yeah the numerology
stuff people look for numbers it's like
dude yeah you're you're going to see a
whole lot of things that have the number
17 or whatever it's like numerical
paradia you just read into it what you
want it was very convenient that I kept
getting flashed 911 in front of my face
over and over and over again on the news
I don't know if that was a coincidence
or not there's something to that
actually I guess I mean that's some kind
of that programming like be afraid be
afraid emergency as if it wasn't clear
enough but I get that but to bring it
back to what Tim was saying really quick
about how you know people are younger
college students now are sort of super
pro Palestine and then people are kind
of realizing how demented that is it's
like it brings it to Black lives matter
yesterday or was the day before with the
parachute imagery that they did you know
that's so sick because there's not even
any great area with that it's not as if
you want to make some sort of nuan
argument that it's even really about
Palestine now it's just directly about
Hamas and directly about the murder that
occurred the murderers in the r and they
doubl down yeah yeah they came out they
were like we weren't proud of that but
we stand by the people who will do
anything necessary it's like right but
you know terrorists link up with
terrorists they stick together birds of
a terrorist feather because that's if
you're clued into the actions of black
lives matter for the past few years
especially if you're you're not just now
associating the word terrorist or
domestic terrorism with black lives
matter you've known that all along but
now it's interesting to see people it
takes something happening a SE away from
them to sort of question those actions
yeah where it's like okay well you also
could not to compare obviously Hamas and
even the most egregious black Liv matter
actions two different worlds but you
know you also could have noticed that
when Chicago was burning San Francisco
was burning Minneapolis right pick a
city you know so it just takes it's
interesting it takes something somewhere
else for people to be like oh maybe
those are the bad guys think about all
the Fortune 500 companies that really
really latched on to that now too do
they walk that back like the NFL does
the NFL still put black lives matter at
the end zone I don't know but they would
have something to answer for that is in
fact true now every conservative can
just as soon as they see that message
from any Corporation call them and be
like why are you supporting Hamas just
pull up that parachute image yeah I was
on a podcast recently and it was a
liberal podcast and they asked me about
they're trying to address all my
controversy one of them was that I'm
anti-black lives matter and they act
like it was going to be a big gotcha and
I'm like is it really that weird because
it's very similar to Peta it's like they
have that platitude name black lives
matter who would disagree with that
people for the ethical treatment of
animals who wouldn't want to treat
animals ethically you have to look at
the actions it's not just a name you
have to look deeper well when you're an
a cult you
don't right right and when you're you
know easily influenced and bullied into
believing things and just have a default
response but again the fact that it
takes something happening a sea away
it's like they had our country on fire
too you know it's interesting that NYPD
is ordering all I love how they phrase
this though look at this story they
order all cops to report in uniform
after a call for protests yo are you
kidding me with this I would have
they're they're not mobilizing every cop
over protests this is Despicable I hope
they have cops in plain clothes with
sniper rifles like in Windows and stuff
like they don't put them all on the
street and like just have them in plain
sight they become targets you got to
have them hidden and ready yeah NYPD is
crazy I think they have like
expeditionary forces I think the NYPD
has Intelligence that that leaves the
city and isn't it the only like Police
Department in America that has like a
their own terrorist like anti-terrorism
unit I don't know I believe maybe like
they have their own counterterrorism
unit I think the thing that makes it
like
particularly in like disturbing in a
familiar way is it's that buildup of
energy where I remember like right
before Co really hit the fan and the
world changed there was kind of a
buildup of energy right before where
it's like okay you're hearing things
about something in China but couldn't
happen and then it did and the world
shut down yeah it feels kind of like
that and again not to man fast anything
or will it into existence well knock on
would Let's uh let's jump to this story
we got this from the post millennial
faculty students and Alum at University
of Washington rally in support of Hamas
terror group yo check this video out
Greg price has it I'm going to play this
for you ready here we
[Applause]
go
there is only one solution there is only
one
solution
re re so let me just break it down for
you they're saying there is no peace on
Stolen land and there is only one
solution in tata Revolution so I want to
make sure the full context is there but
you know everybody understands the
reference to there is only one solution
right they're chanting that on
purpose yeah they don't need to say that
to you you know so when these leftists
come out and they're saying things like
they go it's an it's an open air prison
and these people just want to peacefully
return to their homes I'm like no they
don't right they're screaming from The
River To The Sea yeah they want to
destroy Israel Define peace cuz I don't
think that word really means what you
think it means when you say that yeah if
you obliterate the surface of Earth it
will be peaceful after that but that's
not the kind of peace I'm looking for
interesting idea is there is a you know
that's how we bring about world peace a
great reset fire and Brandon
cataclysm where was that that was uh I
think University of Washington there's
just something so interesting about it
happening to sheltered
Americans protesting something
protesting something that's happening a
as far as they're concerned a world away
and I really do think that the internet
uh I don't think human beings were
really ever designed or created to to
Really handle what the internet can
provide for them in this respect meaning
that you lose lose an insane amount of
perspective to what's going on when you
take that vifer to something that you
can't even experience firsthand or even
would ever want to experience firsthand
that's as as it was the video was
playing Serge I saw you shaking your
head you look pissed was it like were
you just picturing what these people
would be experiencing if if Hamas was to
take over as their government like what
was going through your head when you
when you heard them screaming that it's
just sickening to see people that are
living this first world lifestyle going
to University getting everything paid
for in a lot of cases and ing for the
death of the people across an ocean when
they have nothing to do with this the
conflict they don't understand the roots
of the conflict they don't understand
anything else just know this is current
thing and the current thing I have to
spend on this side and you know what I'm
free today I'm going to go rally for
whatever because I want to make sure
that I get cool social points it's
sickening to me you have this other
video let me play this one for you alone
they want our people dead they want us
K how is is it allowed she asks the
Tweet says Jewish students at w campus
witnessing the pro Palestinian rally
break down they want us dead how are you
allowing this I will only say young
women wipe your tears they're allowed to
speak and I'm glad they're speaking and
you should be happy they're saying these
things because now you know who who they
are and who to avoid yeah imagine if
there are people who are trying to kill
you in secret I'll put it this way if
like there's someone's gunning for you
they want to take your life and they're
lurking in the shadows and you never
even knew it was coming yeah I that's
that's horrible but if you got advanced
warning you go to the cops right you can
say like we like you know hey like
someone's coming after me that's the
point of free speech so we get to watch
a video where they chant that I think
it's fair to say I'm not taking their
word for it when they're saying things
like no peace on Stolen Land There was a
Yale Professor who said settlers are not
civilians and they're chanting there is
only one solution like bro the left lies
it's what they do they say we're just
defending ourselves as they throw bricks
and firebombs at people
mhm and how many times can you fall for
it first of all but also kind of what
you were saying about the whole idea of
protesting even if it's peacefully about
something a see away is particularly I
think it's harmful on a level that they
don't understand obviously because
they're removed from it but also you're
influencing what that country kind of
does in a way the same way we were
talking about Co with all the and in the
middle of that all the George Floyd
stuff it's like why is l protesting
someone that was killed on why why is
the UK and Paris like why and it's it's
you don't understand what's going on and
that's one of the things that's
uncomfortable on days like this where
obviously you know our job to talk about
politics but it's hard to really say
what we want to happen or what should
happen and then it's also even harder
because they're so comfortable saying
what they want to happen you kind of
feel like you have to but we don't
understand it here fully like that well
the funny thing is when George Floyd
happens you get all the conservatives
being like okay like this was bad we
agree and the left being like see we
told you black lives man then the video
comes out where it shows you a bit more
nuanced take on what what happened with
the George Floyd incident and you still
have conservatives being like we've had
conservatives come on the show and be
like yeah okay we saw the footage but we
still think it was bad what happened and
and and now you look at this now you
look at what happened in Israel and you
have the reasonable approach of we don't
like it when civilians are killed yes
Gaza is a hor it's a horrible situation
we're trying to resolve this what can we
do and then you have the left cheering
for the violence cheering for the
killing of civilians calling for more
chanting in the streets there's only one
solution like dude just stop believing
them they're lying to you they go
straight to it oh my God and they're
going to come out now and be like no
that's not what we mean I like I don't
even I don't want to hear it dude like
there was there's a really funny video
Andy know tweeted where a guy claims
that when you go to a pro when what do
he say when you go to a leftist rally or
whatever there's Palestinian Flags when
you go to a white supremacist rally it's
Israeli flags and then he claims that
they they only chant free free Palestine
meanwhile people on the right chant
death to Arabs which literally is not a
chant and does not occur or appear in
any of the rallies held by people on the
right rcking my brain I'm like when was
that oh yeah I saw that video right yeah
they they just lie they're making things
up and they want to kill people and one
of the Twisted things about leftist
rallies and protest and all the things
that are actually not protest because
they're violent having lived in La
during all of Co is that you realize
they're actually kind of parties like
they'll be doing this crazy rhetoric and
this group think but the 90% of people
who show up are because their friends
are there and they're showing up whereas
even the most intense right-wing rallies
which again I'm rocking my brain to
think of really like the worst ones
people are there at least intentionally
and at least they've had like a minute
of thought about what they're saying and
how the impact it may have whereas these
people show up and they're like oh
Rebecca's over here and she's talking
about no peace what it's like that
doesn't mean you have to look at this
look at this story this is uh from the
post-millennial they go on when reached
for comment about the rally for
terrorists W spokesperson Victor Balta
told the post millennial on behalf of U
president Anna cost as a public
institution that abides by the First
Amendment the U neither monitors nor
takes any action against individuals or
student organizations for engaging in
protected speech however cost has a
track record of attempting to prevent
speech in 2019 the W College Republicans
held bake sale to demonstrate racism
from affirmative action by charging
different prices based on ethnicity and
gender in response cost released a
statement condemning the event and
despite claiming University needed
reason to debate on affirmative action
added the so-called affirmative action
bake sale uh that the W College
Republicans are hosting today has no
place in such a debate she also said the
event humiliates and dehumanizes others
it's really interesting these PE look
the yel professor said settlers are not
civilians basically saying that the
killing of civilians in Israel was
justified
and has now like walked them she's like
walked the statements back a little bit
but she doesn't mean it I'm glad these
people were able to speak up and now we
can say you know maybe you shouldn't
work here you're evil and they would say
the same thing about being an American
here in in many cases they would have no
problem making that connection and they
would have no problem with the students
taking those viewpoints even if it's to
their own detriment living here that's
one of the benefits I mean that word is
crazy to use in this context but I'm
sure people know what I mean one of the
only positive things is sort of seeing
who who and getting a lot of clarity
about your own positions we were talking
about that earlier it's like my anti-war
position has never felt I've never felt
more confident with it um but I also am
more confident in who's who and who you
know is beaten those War drums it has
been absolutely like insane to me to
watch what's been happening and realize
that my positions have not changed
through Ukraine through everything in
2020 that my beliefs you know especially
anti-war beliefs do not need to be SED
by either side that it's a bad idea no
matter where it's coming you saw lindsy
grah right yeah his latest thing was
where he said that he wants to bomb Iran
with even with no evidence yep that was
crazy that was insane that guy should
resign that dude is evil and there's and
you look at the responses of the people
talking about this stff and there are
people justifying it and it's it's like
when I when we started seeing all this
stuff it really did become clear to me
how the Patriot Act got passed so
quickly with so much little push back
and that's before the internet age
before the free exchange of information
that we have now where there at least is
now a reasonable push back from all
parties where the ones who are not
seeing red right now can have a
reasonable discussion back then that
wasn't really an option you had you had
a couple of mainstream networks pushing
the war you know the war machine on you
and it worked it worked on it lasted for
like a year and a half too everyone
sorry I didn't know anybody that wasn't
bloodlust from 2001 to 2002 well that
would but there's a weird sometimes I
catch myself almost like longing for
sort of that era in the sense of not the
war part but the unification we all felt
but then you remember it was unification
under so many false pretenses based on a
lie right and I don't even know how much
of that is safe to even talk about here
how many false pretenses so we won't go
into it but you know it is what it is
and every war really starts with
manipulation to some extent which is why
also free exchange information era but
also manipulation era because we have ai
which we're still in the infancy stages
of and we're still having people like
not able to deserve for what's fake and
what's real now and to just too much
information like like you were saying
earlier they say what they say they lie
you don't like most people you do this
for work every day we do this for work
every day you have the time to look into
all of these cases fact check double
check everything you're seeing the
average person who's just going to the
internet to get information on what's
going on isn't doing that the the the
the worst is that they're taking
advantage of the people who are
operating good faith who are just
looking to get information on what
they're supposed to understand people
don't understand what the world really
is without our system of laws and rules
and order it's uh you're in the middle
of the woods and you've you've got your
family and you built a house and you're
like man i' I've I've built up this nice
little place to live and grow food and
then three guys who don't feel like
doing any of that show up mercilessly
beat you and your family and take all
your stuff and leave you for dead and
it's funny because this is my argument
against vegans vegans listen up you see
here's here's my issue the the the the
little uh uh spinach plant hurts nobody
grows its own food sources everything
from the the environment around it
peacefully mining its own business and
then Along Comes This groundhog
groundhog comes over and just
mercilessly destroys that plant
consuming everything about it and I'm
supposed to sympathize with the animal
the animal is the Barbarian who came in
and killed the peaceful farmer right so
so it's like if there was a guy farming
minding his own business and then a
bandit came and killed the farmer and
took all his stuff who would you side
with depends if the if the farmer's
father had stolen the land from the
Bandit's father now we're talking now we
have but this is actually an interesting
uh uh point if you have an innocent
farmer who grew his own he has he has
land there's nobody there it was just
wild and it's like let's say it's 3,000
years ago and he's minding his own
business then Marauders come kill him
take all the stuff and leave we
obviously side with the farmer and say
it's awful they did this but you take a
look at how the left operates and it
really does follow this this line so
it's like it's interesting that they're
like an overlap between leftists and
vegans I'm not really ragging on vegans
I know a lot of conservative vegans I
know you're saying though but like my
point is the left tends to side with the
with the thieves with the people who who
lie cheat and steal and strip value
they're Predators uh and and and also
they're also predators in the more
literal sense of what predators are like
Joe Biden is a predator but they also
they a lot of it is like in our media
we've baked the idea of the ends
justifying the means for a very long
time and so for a lot of them they feel
as if their actions however abhorent are
Justified because a lot of times it
really does come down to is it class
struggle is it race struggle uh in this
case they're saying that what's going on
they're attacking their oppressors
therefore it is okay and that has
permeated all levels of our culture
whether it's people pushing back on
police because they believe that they're
being held down by the police that
carries all the way all the way up
through to global conflict you know some
oppressors are better than other
oppressors and if you've got a pick
which one you want to be oppressed by
whether it's a banking system or a
militant system you got to pick like you
might maybe you'll end up on top of the
game at some point but I don't think so
I think there's probably about 10 10
humans that are doing that right now
that's that's the reality that's my
point if nobody nobody wants to live in
a true state of conflict or War right I
the people that that gloat about it and
laugh you put those people in the middle
of the woods for a couple weeks and
they'll be crying and begging and and I
know this because I remember during
Occupy Wall Street story I often tell uh
they the land was was gifted to the
occupiers and I asked I asked people how
long do you think the occupiers lasted
on that Farmland how long do you
think I don't know bunch of leftists
protesting in New York farmland is
gifted saying you can use this Farmland
to live off the grid and be sustainable
maybe 12 hours oh that's a little you
know a little better than that two weeks
okay yeah two week couple weeks and then
they and then I remember talking to a
friend who said I was working I would
wake up and work and then work till I
went to sleep and I'm like uhhuh I
you're surprised by this yeah that's
what life is like outside of the luxury
of the United States and the Petro
dollar and all this stuff you work and
they also don't really obviously have a
concept of so you can wrap your head
around maybe the more advanced leftist
brain can wrap its head around the idea
that you know bad things happening these
other places but the idea that yeah that
happens and there's no justice for it in
most scenarios too so the idea that you
can then seek Justice for it is
completely removed as well who who are
you going to complain to that's why it's
funny when they're like universal
healthcare and Healthcare is a human
right I'm like so who are you going to
force to give you the healthare and then
if that person is human and you've
stripped them of their rights is it
really a human right right that's that's
like way more thinking into it than they
than most of them give to it anything
that involves the labor of another human
being is not a human right right yeah of
course and and what you said earlier
about how their idea of who the
oppressor is and who isn't is completely
warped you see it with their you know
landlord discourse oh that's it's like
so as someone who worked their entire
life to maybe buy
even a rinky dink house and then manages
to rent it out to someone is
somehow like worthy of being bashed for
that or not in a position of being
harmed if that renter destroys the house
or doesn't pay rent it's like what these
people don't understand like you know I
I I I I had a house we moved I rented it
out and then I sold it as soon as I
could because I'll tell you I'll tell
you what happens you're like the the
Assumption of the left because look
they're not bright people that's just
that's just the reality of it they don't
understand what it means to be a
landlord because they assume all
landlords are slumlords okay be a
slumlord fine whatever but uh you you
have to maintain and work for the people
who live there they are paying you you
are providing a service that's it
imagine o owning a restaurant and being
like as the owner of the restaurant I
can sit back and do nothing someone
comes in and says I'm giving you money
for food and you say get it yourself
they're going to be like okay I'm
leaving give me my money back you have a
you have a house and then AC stops
working yeah you're getting a phone call
you got to pay for it and so basically
all the money you're making in rent off
a single property or a couple properties
is just going to the bank to pay to
maintain the house now that being said
if you finance a house and you have
people renting it out you are Building
Wealth for yourself so you're working
right but people still choose to rent or
not and and one of the biggest issues is
i i i reject so much of the millennial I
can't afford to buy a house and things
like this because I do know it is
difficult it is difficult but I've met
way too many New York hipsters who don't
want to give up their luxuries they
refuse to have to save I'm not kidding
man like I 90% of the people I worked
with when I lived in Brooklyn it's like
well do you want to buy a house I do
well here's how much you're going to
need down you can buy you can get a
condo in New York you can get a small a
small house outside of New York and then
commute in well I don't want to commute
in well okay like property in New York
is ridiculous expensive that I get but
that's premium real estate so how about
instead of spending 300 bucks every
weekend you keep the 00 bucks and then
after a year you can have a down payment
now they don't want to do it and you
know what there's something so sad about
that because this is kind of something I
identified very early on cuz I've kind
of always even when I was a teenager and
you tend to be more socially liberal and
just liberal in general when you're in a
teenager by the time I was 18 or 19 was
when I kind of shifted that and I
realized that's because I'm not a
pessimist there's something very
pessimistic about the leftist mindset as
well because it's not just that they're
demonizing the landlord and see him as
an oppressor it's because inherently
they believe they could never achieve
that and even though granted it's
difficult to buy a house like you said
it's partly because they believe they
could never achieve that whereas I
always believed I could achieve anything
I wanted and so that's kind of how I
realized very early on that's not the
ideology for me social media has also
like really really ramped that up like
Doomer content that's designed to
destroy your morale and hope for any
type of brighter future like half the
memes you'll end up seeing they are it's
so funny that you mentioned that cuz the
do you remember maton EV and the guy who
mentioned um okay so he had a thing he
went to like protests and was like we
love landlords and it was like I think
that might have been the greatest thing
that happened in all of 2023 because the
landlord discussion is one of the most
ridiculous ones that's going on right
now and they've just been inundated with
all of these all of these things it's
it's people who are actually the funny
thing about it they're actually talented
they're just talented at creating
content that's destroying the morale of
other people there's this guy who does
these videos where he lists existential
crises and really really bad things but
he says it with a smile on his face with
really really positive words and that's
the type of stuff that seeps into their
brains like I'm never going to own a
home I'm going to work until I'm 80 like
in in all the while there's like cheery
music playing in the background and
that's and they're on social media all
day so they're being inundated with this
content endlessly who wouldn't be
demoralized and it and it becomes warped
because you see it spread out in so many
different ways like the fat positivity
movement which is inherently a leftist
movement it's like they really will
convince you that being fat sick and
dying literally is a virtue is positive
like living the opposite of a positive
life is positive modern society I think
has destroyed the human human psyche in
a lot of ways we should be working
non-stop like but the problem is for
whatever reason I never understood this
there are people who are like I don't
want to work I want to do nothing it's
like hold on if your argument is you
want to work on something specific and
not the thing you're working on on that
I get yeah like hey I'm a restaurant
manager but I really want to be a
software engineer so I'm going taking
night classes to learn how to code and
then I'm going to go and work for a firm
that I get that's like I'm not working
where I want to be but a lot of these
people want to do nothing they they
they're just like I shouldn't have to
work I should be able to just lay there
and and and consume resources from other
people and a lot of those people who do
they actually like the what like to what
you said your mindset you would see it
as a net positive to be able to have
something to work on after your day job
because you're passion about it they
find it almost as an affront to them
that they would have to have a day job
to then work on the thing that they want
to advance in yeah let's uh and that's
the college lie that we sold them we've
got this tweet from Jonathan greenblat
oh he's uh he runs the ADL the
Anti-Defamation League CEO of ADL CEO he
tweeted the post shared in recent Days
by black lives matter chapters in
Chicago and la and other Fringe groups
glorifying the Hamas terrorists who used
hang gliders to infiltrate Israel
slaughtering over 1,000 Innocents is
beyond sick and twisted it's
anti-semitic dehumanizing and could
prompt violence so uh just want to point
out they're not hang gliders they're
paragliders they different hang gliders
are the fixed Wing glider and
paragliders are parachutes have Motors
but uh uh right they have Motors yeah
but I'm wondering will the
Anti-Defamation League now uh uh put
black lives matter on their list of
anti-Semitic hate groups they better and
every time I see that for which I've
seen it a few over the past few days
obviously it still feels like it's not
real because the audacity how bold it is
dude these people are out Marching In
the Streets there is only one solution
okay like crazy they they bro uh 10
years ago Occupy Wall Street people were
posting on my Facebook just never forget
you're first against the wall these are
people threatening me with death yeah
like this is this is not surprising that
they came out what what is what is kind
of surprising to me I guess is that
finally this is what broke the machine
yeah and now you've got a whole bunch of
Democrats being like whoa there's like
some former Washington Post lady being
like I had never understood that the
left was very anti-semitic and now I'm
starting to see it Jake Tapper being
like a wakeup call for people to realize
antisemitism on the left it's like I
don't know when the BLM people proudly
stated on video that they wanted to end
Israel was that not surprising to you
that part I mean if you paid any
attention I don't remember her name but
one of the it was the female black lives
matter leaders getting in yeah she's
been getting in like semi cancellations
like once a year over the crazy
anti-semitic stuff she says so that's
not surprising but I think what takes me
back every time I look at this is how
there's no room for nuance even if
they're trying to with that I stand with
palisin as if we don't see that they're
standing with Hamas specifically and
it's about the
murders you know let me let me all of it
yeah uh I'm not sure who this is I just
quickly searched for it lionhearted on
Twitter says BLM co-founder Patrice
kuller said exactly where BLM stood on
the Palestine Israel conflict in 2015
quote Palestine is our generation South
Africa if we don't step up boldly and
courageously to end the imperialist
project imperialist project called
Israel we are doomed I mean like what
does that mean to end Israel I mean one
thing I think she spelled it out right
yeah means one thing right what did they
say one solution what was that yeah I
would say they're being pretty specific
and you have to believe them yeah this
is part of the problem with the
oppressor oppress make sure we get Fox
News in there here's here's our source
from uh officially reporting on it
Patrice cullers here's the video we have
a oh I got it right here is our
generation in South Africa and the other
thing I'll say is Palestine is our
generation in South Africa and
if o shut up dude if if we don't step up
uh boldly and courageously to and the
the imperialist project that's called
Israel wow were DED dude dude dude I
here's here's the thing with South
Africa we were like everyone must live
together in harmony it's like not gone
so well I mean Serge knows better than
anybody your home country yeah but but I
will just
say I think a a great solution would be
how do we get everyone to live
peacefully together Israel pales
Israelis Palestinians whatever how do we
stop the fighting I don't know if it's
possible
but that's what we'll strive for for her
to go on to say and
Israel the the purpose of their of their
project is of of like their goals are
fairly obvious so I don't understand how
this is 2015 where BLM a BLM co-founder
is saying to end Israel and a the ADL is
just now like oh Heaven's me I can't
believe the people that we've supported
for a decade are now saying this thing
it's because of that platitude name
black lives matter it makes it so
impenetrable that they have to be this
specific for anyone to you know wipe the
crust out of their eyes and be like oh
they're the bad guys for the average
person who's not paying very very close
attention to the sociopolitical
situation I've had a couple of people
who uh were very um big on the idea of
compelled speech during 2020 that you
had to make a statement on all this
stuff um who unfollowed me um refollow
after this situation what's going on now
cuz I think for certain people I I can't
I can't speak whether because of that
realiz I would imagine that this is a
more clear-cut example uh that the world
you were sold before isn't as simple as
you think it is I'll tell you what it is
it's that most of these people were were
s were standing around staring at people
with pitchforks and thought to
themselves if I call this out they'll
Pitchfork and torch me so I'll just
agree with them and go along with it
that's a big chunk of it that's a big
chunk and so now that all of a sudden
the these people are supporting
terrorism and the killing of innocent
civilians they're like oh no am I on the
yeah guess what you're on the wrong side
of history and now they're panicking now
they're saying uh oh what do I do well I
don't know it's kind of scary right you
were on the wrong side of the history
the wrong side of history as as y'all
tried describing it for for the whole
time and now all those protests you you
took part in oh man I'm I'm going to
it's going to be a fun Thanksgiving when
I'm talking to family members being like
remember when you held up that communist
red salute and chanting for these people
say right now to the family at the table
how you agree with the slaughter of
civilians and even worse all those
billions of dollars that went straight
to those mansions for those disgusting
Founders and people in the organization
I mean how disgusting that's the the
legacy of what you fought for if you
were out on those streets even if you
had every good intention and you really
were affected in in a profound way by
the George Floyd or any other Injustice
against a black person I mean that's
obviously like a different story than
Injustice but it's you were deceived and
but the part do you forgive them no I
don't I I I I don't I don't think so
much that they're deceived most of these
people knew what they were saying was
wrong but they wanted to stand alongside
power they were either cowards or evil
yeah there's the banality of evil along
with that I think it's I think it's the
for some of it I think a lot of it is
just that they're the average person who
decided to put you know post a black
square or go to these protests I I think
it's cuz they're not looking that
closely into it and they had a very
visceral emotional reaction to what
happened I'm I'm not talking about
someone who passively posted I'm talking
about the people who message you being
like dud what's wrong with you why are
you doing this the exactly these people
willfully stood behind evil because evil
had power yep and we live in a time
where so many people do feel powerless
that the idea that you can DM or or tell
anyone that you know in your life that
you are morally Superior to them whether
you say that directly specifically or
just in your actions you're just
unfollow it's like people leap at that
you know and I realized that very
clearly when I started my channel
talking about politics it's like I lost
every friend I had I had to get a new
friend group but obviously was worth it
but you know people they weren't your
friends I I I have friends who are still
relatively Lefty and they're just like
we're friends we've been do we forgive
them when they come around because I'm
noticing on a lot of issues lately a lot
of people coming around the trans kid
thing is a big deal because I've been
ringing those alarms for years and all
of a sudden I have a big uptick and
people jamming me like you know what now
I'm kind of seeing that that was a
really bad thing I I I forgive them but
I don't trust their their judgment
anymore yes correct you uh uh you
forgive them but you recognize that
they're likely going to turn in a dime
the moment power an opportunity arises
but the point is the left was willing to
capitalize on on cowards who who would
Empower them and if those cowards are
fleeing then say okay
fine if you want to do work if if look
if you got two groups and one they're
both building castles and one group
flees to you and says we'll help you
build your Castle you say sure start
laying bricks but we're going to keep an
eye on you because we don't trust you
and we think you're evil like you you
forgive them because you have to give an
opportunity to do the right thing
otherwise they'll just never come around
but you keep that eye on but you don't
trust them because the these people are
fickle and swayed by power easily easily
the thing was a big one cuz now
obviously they they really tried in
mid-september to kind of see if if they
could get a foot in again The
Establishment can we do the masks again
can we do the they they were turned down
even by college students was which was
actually pretty cool um but I I posted
about that and it was overwhelmingly
this consensus from everyone that yeah
we should stand against lockdowns again
in Mass again and it's so crazy to think
there was a time not that long ago where
that position was like essentially I
mean you said that it's like you were
saying the nword that you didn't want to
put a mask on you know it's treated like
that you couldn't have that position so
people do come around but it doesn't
take away that they were complicit when
it happened you know all the kids right
now that are behind in in school in
development by years and years that
can't read in second grade it's like you
still caused that so it's hard for me to
forgive but you do you're right and the
worst of the worst are the ones who just
take whatever the most popular position
is anyways did you see Ryan Long's
new greatest work since the woke vers
racist magnum opus yes like it might be
the great like when I saw that I'm like
oh he's going to be perfect at this and
that's exactly what we're looking at
right people have been fed they've been
spoonfed unbelievably simple narratives
for the last six seven years I mean
longer than that but really in the last
six seven years spoonfed simple
narratives now they're like well here's
one that's just not quite so cut and dry
Ryan long on YouTube Ryan long comedy
actor doesn't what does it it's like
actor doesn't know whether to support
Palestine or Israel it's genius you got
to watch it it's it's it's masterfully
done I never miss a stance he's and then
he go it's a it's a sketch but then he
actually goes and asks people it's like
who are you supporting palestin or
Israel like no it's just some guy like
eating lunch guys yeah it's complicated
I found this like so uh interesting that
a potential Communist Revolution in the
United States was disrupted by islamism
or whatever you want to call it by like
some external because people are like
Nazism no communism Nazism communism Naz
like ah and then all of a sudden you
realize whoa aliens are real like
there's outside forces
well alien being outside the system I
mean it was kind of tongue and cheek
joke but there's some external force
that comes in that maybe a bigger threat
than what you thought your internal uh
conundrum was all over and like and then
you get this communist I don't know I
don't want to call Black lives matter
communist straight up but you get this
they have they have a lot of there's
communist Tendencies within it I see you
see supporting Marxist it's the
oppressor versus oppressed if you're
constantly supporting the oppressed
you're always going to look for
oppression you're always going to create
oppression let me pull up this tweet and
then we'll we'll carry the conversation
because this is a good example of of of
the left and what what what they do Andy
no tweets multiple cars in Ladera
Heights Los Angeles vandalized with
swastikas setting off fears a white
supremacist was targeting the black
majority neighborhood antifa helped
bring attention to the incidents last
week Robert hymore was arrested he's a
37-year-old black male nice what the guy
who committed white supremacy was a
black male yes and so there there are a
lot of stories like this there used to
be a thing called like uh what was it
the hate crime hoax map yeah like there
were so many that were proven and
debunked that this is what you get I
feel like the modern state of American
politics is regular people and like
people like us are just desperately
trying to figure things out and keep
things together and then you have
conservatives who are in alignment to a
great degree with that but want more
traditional values and are willing to
have those debates and the farle who was
completely lying about everything and
calling for like murder and Terror and
you name it and that's so like one of
the most sick things about when you
finally kind of realize that a lot of
the hate crimes are faked and that there
is this like demand and a supply that
isn't meeting the demand is then you
start to question a lot of things cuz
it's like okay so you have this entire
ideology structured around who's the
oppressor who's not and as we've
established we know that that's they're
warped in their sense of that but it's
like that's the Telltale sign right
there and they never truly address how
many are faked either I mean I feel like
once a week there's like you know gay
man has you know the anti-gay FS slur
written on his car and then it's like
his cousin comes out and says he put
that on there and then no one addresses
it ever again what was like the the
Bubba Wallace one where it was like
the the garage pole and they're like
it's a and the FBI went out there to
investigate your tax dollars at work
ladies and gentlemen sort of it's your
your fractional Reserve banking system
stripping your resources away from you
so they can go inv a gar pull rope Jesse
smallet is really the only example I can
think of on the top of my head where
like you know people Everyone kind of
had to call out the BS eventually but
people hung on as long as they could no
but they a lot of people never
apologized for that oh no yeah remember
remember uh uh uh When Alan Page went on
was it co bear whatever and was like
screaming like and it's just like bro
the whole thing was fake and it was
plainly obvious to most people and then
she had her own little Rainbow JY SM at
moment she said that she was in West
Hollywood the gay well now now we're
talking about Elliot page oh I'm sorry
different I'm the I'm the one
that um but she had her own little
wannabe moment because these actors need
to stop writing their own stuff oh my
God how am I the worst one this how am I
the worst one um zzm said uh no but okay
Elliot wow that person it shouldn't be
the that person said that they were
accosted in West Hollywood by someone
who screamed I'm going to gay bash you
so they can't even make it believable
Jesse Smet is like Chicago attacked by
trumpers and Elliot Paige is saying
someone was homophobic in West Hollywood
and if you ever been there every street
Rainbow Gas Station and and like someone
saying something so specific pretty sure
when you're going to get gay bashed they
don't tell you they're going to do it
they just do it yeah it would have been
like like in West Hollywood of all
places of all places that's that's could
have at least said Compton you could we
said you went down a wrong Street
downtown LA and be like it would have
been like the people who did that to
like that supposedly did it to SM Smet
said like I'm going to do a racism on
exactly I'm going to do a racism country
but they said this is Maga country like
come on we isn't exactly straight
country Elliott but you know taking
advantage of the fact that people don't
know just how cold that 16 degrees below
zero is in the midwest that time of year
thought that but but also the area where
Smet was is like a non mostly
non-residential area it's like B next to
a bunch of corporate offices is and so
like me because of that me and my
friends would skate down there because
no one's there to yell at you so when I
heard that story right away I was like
what he was by the NBC building like
right that's how I felt when I saw the
Elliot page St I'm like the rainbow
Street someone said they're going to get
okay okay I mean it's it's but it's it's
also sad though because people really
are even though it's rare victims of
that kind of stuff and it's so horrible
to lie about considering the big news
that's happening now with like Israel
Palestine forgive me friends but it is
very difficult to believe them when
they're like Israel is just
indiscriminately doing all of these
things I'm like I just you know man look
I don't know because it's it's a long
it's an on 75 year conflict and longer
than that technically going back
thousands of years but all I can say is
the left lies about everything so sorry
there's something bizarrely impressive
though about their dedication to a
narrative that like we said that Supply
doesn't meet that demand they'll make it
meet it they will make it they will
artificially inflate thing they'll make
it so there's something bizarrely sickly
impressive about it but it's also
financially beneficial for the media who
become useful idiots for those types of
you know at the at the lowest end of the
spectrum they're the people that are
just uh they're just doing what they're
told and it's what the it's what the
media wants from it and then the worst
are the activist reporters who are happy
to kind of OBC the truth in the in the S
you know for the sake of spinning a
narrative a certain way and there's
money to be made from it in that
direction not just social change yeah
it's very clickable obvious Elliot page
AC costed really clickable by the way
that speaking of which that if I
remember correctly so just don't I
believe there was a book coming out at
that time there also there's always the
like we we kind of we call it like the
uh the bad decision to Memoir Pipeline
on our show because it's a lot of
celebrities right they they do bad
things in their 20s which they're
celebrated for their 30s come around the
roles start to dry up well what is it
now it's book time so they have to write
a book I wrote a book it's coming out uh
tomorrow actually and and I have to tell
you this very horrifying story Ian told
me that he was selling me an unlimited
soul ring but it was a revised soul ring
I was never the same after that yeah
never the same I kep the unlimited one
for myself nerds nerd nerds around the
world are outraged you must buy the book
if you want to see the F there's no book
I'm kidding you should write a book
that' be it's a good timing the way I
believed that a book coming out you
could probably write like a N9 page book
like 100 million copies I was wrong
million copies you must buy my book to
understand just how wronged I was it
really is the thing though now like we
we cuz what we read these stories and
I'm just like I get through the first
paragraph and I'm like last paragraph
when does the book come out oh it comes
out in a month that's perfect they have
to just in time to go on their media
tour right CU if you really wanted to
raise the alarm about homophobes running
through the street right you would have
done it a lot sooner than the week your
book's coming out because he said that
that was like a couple years prior I'm
like so maybe waren the other LGBT
people they're going to get bashed on
that street before that right what if
Jesse Smet was like look I don't even
have a book coming out why would I
lie right and he's he's in trial and
it's like the defense says he doesn't
have a book coming out and they're like
oh well this man's innocent right it
really happened then damn this the
racism or I guess the black and white
gay straight stuff over the last seven
years six years feels like cake like
icing on the cake they we don't need it
like now that this is going off in in
Israel and even Putin's like yo this is
insane protect the women and the
children you guys kind of mentality and
maybe he maybe he's not but I don't
think he's going in and executing women
and and kidnapping children I don't
think that's the Russian they want land
so it's like I I think it's almost as if
I mean and and then John Kirby was it
John Kirby the uh speaker what is his
house White House spokesperson John
Kirby announced the funding for
Ukraine's quote coming near to the end
of the rope we're done we're done
funding it Ukraine it's over well they
got a phone call and they said guys we
we we got to fund Israel it's like all
right that's exactly what's happening
they're like we need to Red divert funds
what matters a lot of people think the
the principal motivator for Ukraine is
not actually geopolitics energy gas it
is the military-industrial complex needs
to spend money yes needs needs to be get
given contracts and so after Afghanistan
they're like what do we do quick we need
another War they Lobby for it yeah now
that Israel's heating up they're like o
okay we don't need Ukraine anymore guys
uh seninsky you're on your own there was
that tweet that said zalinski just
became America's side
chick right that's that's pretty
accurate oh Ukraine y don't be surprised
if the US is backing away now current
thing I don't necessarily think it'll be
like a religious War I mean who cares
what you call it but if there's a World
War like where where uh Egypt and Israel
and the United States and Germany and
India all go to war with China and and
uh Iran and and and all these Russia is
the center lynchpin of all of this
wherever Russia goes wins so we need
them on our side they're in the center
of it all and that was what was so
demented about the Trump presidency how
like demonized he was for attempting to
have a somewhat cordial relationship
with Putin yeah it's like you can see a
drop of their argument with like okay
there's certain things to criticize but
you definitely don't want them against
you right no definitely not and they
they've had a lot of issues with this as
well within CIA and within the fact they
were in Afghanistan as well back in the
80s so I don't know I'm surprised he
even came out and said anything I could
see a war breaking out and then it goes
really bad for the Americans and the
Israelis half of Israel God forbid is
whatever the worst case scenario and
Putin watches and they stay neutral and
they watch and then it gets to a point
where the Arabs do some horrific things
to humanity and Putin can no longer sit
by and he joins the Americans and then
ends the war that's what I said last
night the thing I'm most afraid of is is
that the Shia and Sunni are able to get
past their their their Collective
aggression towards each other and say
like we have to deal with Israel that's
the thing that I'm most concerned about
what what is what is the root of their
aggression towards each other do you
know and Sunni disagree who is a
spiritual successor on Earth of Muhammad
who is a prophet and that's because his
daughter Fatima was that her name uh no
he had many I don't know ex basically it
was like his brother gave had a had a
group I think it was his brother and his
daughter they have yeah theyve they've
disagreed with the lineage of who is the
spiritual I think it was his brother or
it was one of his generals or was like
one of his main disciples or something
it like descends from from that man and
then the other disciples come from the
daughter and could be I'm pretty sure
that's what it is don't want to speak
out of turn no no that's understand it's
it's very so it's similar to like how
the ARA how the Muslims and the uh Jews
came out of Abraham's children Isaac and
ishma both had their tribes and same
within Islam there was two tribes that
came from
Muhammad let's jump to this story from
the New York Post doxing truck drives
around Harvard showing names photos of
students who blamed Israel for Hamas
attacks that's the that's the story
giant video screens hung on the sides of
trucks posting the names of these
individuals so the story is a bunch of
student groups signed a letter that
explicitly said the only the only one to
blame for this is Israel and it's led to
a major backlash a truck is now posting
their names and you've got more CEOs
signing on saying they will never hire
any one of these students who signed one
of these letters and I'm sitting back
putting my feet I'm be like don't don't
don't look at me for help hello cuz
that's the same thing y'all did for
every other issue every other time so hi
that's Karma it's like y'all you you we
we begged you not to do this we said
cancel culture is wrong people should
should have their free speech there's
there are certain limits I don't think
everything's absolute right some people
don't want to associate I get it but the
line the left Drew was so ridiculous
like comedy banned you know a 10 year
you made a comment 10 years ago banned
uh oh we we misinterpreted what you said
you're fired okay you made the rules
buddies yeah you wanted to sign on to
this they thought they were on the right
side of history but they weren't and now
they will never get jobs again talk
about wasting your your your uh College
o must be brutal for
them and especially considering like you
said I think it was you brought the
point it's like most of them actually I
think it was Tim sorry that they're just
jumping on because their peers are so
you're not even thinking about it and
you mess yourself up there's TW thinking
about it I can't remember the guy who
said it I could probably pull it up but
he said you know I'm not going to I'm
not going to cut anybody some slack over
signing this but you know got to
understand a lot of students didn't even
know what the letter was when they
signed on to it and I'm like wow that's
even worse yeah it is yeah then you kind
of deserve it even more actually nothing
to do with what they signed it's the
fact that they signed it at all that
they would they would be kept out of it
I do have an issue with the idea of
compelled speech though a little like
there was a Breitbart article today or
yesterday it was like these top the top
10 Instagram celebrity the top 10
Instagram celebrities with the most
followers who haven't said anything
about Israel I was like I thought I was
like I thought 10 years ago we or five
years ago we said these people are
idiots who don't know anything about
foreign policy and we didn't care what
their opinions were I don't like that
either I don't like the idea of either
side telling me or anyone that I have to
have an opinion on something so this is
a professor at Harvard who tweeted I
yield to no one in my revulsion at the
statement apparently made on behalf of
30 plus Harvard student groups but
please everybody take a deep breath many
in these groups never saw the statement
before it went out in some case those
approving did not understand exactly
what they were approving probably some
were naive and foolish this is not a
time where uh where it is constructive
to vilify individuals and I am sorry
it's happening oh a Harvard Professor he
probably agrees with them but let me
just say uh my friend you know there
were there were a lot of Nazis I love
we'll just go straight Godwin's law on
these people because it's related to
Israel there were a lot of lowlevel Nazi
soldiers who did not know what was going
on but they loaded those people up on
trains and trucks all the same and were
held accountable held accountable for it
just doing your job is not an excuse
these people at Harvard signed onto a
statement empowering it and it was
shockingly offensive to a lot of people
now I don't know that my personal values
like I would fire someone who said
something shocking and offensive to an
extreme degree I'd probably just talk to
him about it and be like I don't know
man like consider the implications of
what you're saying and whether it's
strategically you know valuable and then
I I I do have my lines though I think
everybody does if I put it this way if
you were hanging out with your buddies
at a bar and one guy got up and started
screaming racial slurs at somebody you'd
be like dude stop what are you doing
like knock it off that's not cool and so
that's basically what's happening right
now the issue I take with the farle was
that their cancel culture was always
extreme
a guy there was a race car driver whose
dad said the nword in the 80s so his
sponsors canel on him like that's nuts
there there Sarah Silverman did
blackface 10 years ago so they get her
fired from a movie I'm like well you
know she she she made her bed she's
going to lay in it that's crazy if
somebody has an extreme opinion then I
think it's like you criticize him for it
you question them for it and depends on
what that that the the severity of the
opinion the problem was the left was
getting people fired and canceled for
the most tepid conservative opinions
nothing right and they still do I mean
we can't also pretend as if like that's
completely over it's definitely softened
but you know that still happens all the
time so fire with fire I guess it's not
fire with fire it's them trying to set a
fire and burning themselves and me
sitting back and being like me out of it
yeah live by the sword die by the that's
that whole that whole thing is like you
know you get what you give we talk about
a lot like the the cult will come for
you if you yeah live by the sword Die By
The Sword it's an ancient phrase um that
like if you live your life canceling
people well you're going to surround
yourself with other people that love to
cancel people and then watch out one day
for you comes around but that doesn't
mean I won't forgive them and welcome
them back but I do not trust people that
snap to Crazy judgments of others they
don't even consider themselves friends
they consider themselves allies they
yeah they're comrades but that's that
slippery slope that they never seem to
understand either you know it's like to
them it's a fallacy to anyone who pays
attention to how life Works Humanity
Works history works that's not a fallacy
at all live by the sword comes from the
Bible oh does Matthew 26:52 yep was that
something then said Jesus unto him put
up against again thy sword into his
place for all they that take the sword
Shall Perish with the sword yes what is
he saying like so grab your sword and
get and arm yourself is that what he's
saying or he say put it back no it's
it's it's a proverb it's basically
saying live by the sword Die By The
Sword yep that's where it comes from I
feel bad if I was Sheamus I would have
known that when I was right Sheamus is
probably at home right now being like
you didn't know that you said an ancient
sorry Sheamus come back on the oh I need
you but I guess also the part of it is
they don't really realize it's a sword
to begin with right like they don't when
they're when they're ruining people's
lives over the most minor infraction
which they are so accustomed to doing
they don't actually think about that
person's life after in any regard so to
them it's nothing so the slightest bit
of blowback to them it's like maybe
we'll rethink some things now actually I
think the worst of them do think about
it I think they want you homeless in a
box they want you they want you to
suffer uh and die alone on the streets
with no money that's why it's so
Insidious that it's not enough to just
have you scolded it's not enough to just
have you criticized you have to be given
you have to have everything taken from
you before and and there that blood lust
is never quenched right and they'll say
things like it's about accountability
culture it's like first of all who are
you to hold me accountable for anything
you're not God you're not my parents
you're not any you're no one but it's
like that's not accountability when your
entire life is dismantled because of a
tweet from 10 years ago and that's more
on the extreme example of what happens
but it's not as if that's super rare
that happens there's something higher
than both God and your parents they're
the offended and that's that's
apparently above all yeah yeah
accounting is like when you're taking an
accurate cost benefit cost analysis and
if you're over accounting if you're
doing it wrong maybe you're charging too
much for the value like ruining
someone's entire livelihood because they
weree blackface 10 years ago I feel like
is over overdoing it it's a miscount for
you to determine what the accountability
should be is like like even that even if
I'm going to be held accountable let me
figure out how to make amends with
myself with what I've done you don't
tell me what to do well if you have
black face you can still be the prime
minister of Canada so yes it's okay or
uh joar oh or Governor I forgot about
that true but we we never knew if it was
it was blackface or the clan costume
which one he never answered that's the
best part he's like's like like to this
day he's going to take that to his grave
it'll be in his Memoir when he writes a
book Schrodinger's racism are you
talking about no trau not
TR the Govern yes yes who not Northam oh
Governor Ralph noram yeah and that's
just to distract you from the whole
9month abortion thing yeah yeah which is
crazy it's wild I I was just like
getting uh like all that I feel like
we're talking about racism cancel
culture that stuff is like it feels like
vomit that's like kind of out of me now
but I keep it's like still with me kind
of but then I think about like Israel
Palestine and it's and then I feel like
I'm burn
so I'm not sure this is crazy this 2019
it's not four years
ago blackface and KKK Garb and we don't
know which one he was so he is in a
super position of both offensive
costumes at the same
time like I actually clone myself and
I'm both people at the same time well no
it's just like if he's not going to tell
us which one he did then he's
both that's crazy because you it's
because like both has like their own
like individual problems with it that
make it worse so he's like he doesn't
want you attaching whatever's worse
about either one of those in particular
ones to that exact costume D the crazy
thing is it was in their yearbook or
something yeah yeah yeah it was or I
think I think Trudeau was also I think
it a yearbook thing but that's also kind
of the reion history that goes on and
people really pretend as if like Nazi
jokes were not acceptable even like 10
years ago there's silver dressed up like
Hitler on Conan or something like that
everyone kind of did it that's the
reason you can pull up all these
mainstream celebrities it's like there's
a reason why they weren't canceled in
the moment and then it aired on live
television it's because we kind of did
have a sense of humor who did you say
dressed up as a a Nazi on S Silverman oh
really interesting as Hitler I'm pretty
sure okay and it's okay because she's
Jewish that was what the whole point was
at least I'm really I'm concerned comedy
is okay like you had count dankula's
famous video where he he had the Pug
doing the salute and it was it was it
was like he said the cutest thing in the
world doing the most repugnant thing
possible that was the of it he was
insulting Nazis and then there's a story
about like some guy actually in Germany
trained his dog to do it and then he got
in trouble cuz they were like how dare
you insult us but they they tried they
they tried to lock him up yeah Mak a
video well they did didn't they actually
but but he got he got he went to cor I
think I think he had to pay a fine or
something he did get he did get arrested
I'm pretty sure yeah he he got arrested
I'm pretty sure he got tried for and
went to prison he didn't go to prison I
don't think he went to prison believe I
I don't know I thought he' pay a fine or
something but then he made another video
where he had his he has has a white pug
and a black pug and he made the black
pug do the black power fist which is
effectively the same thing that video
was so good and then like as as he as
it's doing it there's a knock on the
door and he's like oh no it's the labor
party and then he has to like hide all
of his books and then he's like I got to
hide books and then he he's going
through his bookshelf he's like uh and
then he grabs the Tora on he's like oh
crap oh crap doesn't know what to do
yeah it looks like he was fin yeah he
was 800 and I mean that type of humor
that was very very there's actually a
picture of like Taylor Swift at like a
Halloween costume from like 9 and the
guy she's with has a swasa on his shirt
and like she like but the thing is
they'll just Overlook it if you're if if
you sell enough pumpkin spice lates an
albums like they'll just let it go yeah
dude but also there's something to be
said about the fact that it wasn't that
offensive back then people would see it
as funny even though obviously it's
egregious imagery and it reminds you of
obviously the atrocities but there was a
time when people didn't necessarily
internalize it as that person actually
being a Nazi it was really just a
Halloween yeah we'll get back to the
place where symbols aren't the same
thing as actions it sometimes they they
wave in and out of reality like you
forget what a symbol used to mean or it
means something new and then it no
longer means it like what's more what's
more vile having a swastic on your shirt
or killing someone kill or or or
celebrating and defending those who do
like this is the point when it people
need to understand the the actual moral
qualms that exist with cancel culture
it's not so much that someone said
something shocking and offensive so they
got fired it's that what they said
actually wasn't shocking offensive and
they got fired so when like Sarah
Silverman does a bit about blackface
she's trying to be a shock comedian we
get what she's doing she's not literally
intending to insult black people but she
got fired from a movie over it that's
ridiculous when Harvard students sign a
letter blaming Israel for the mass
murdering of civilians then we kind of
like H I can look you should not hire
these people and I'll tell you why it's
not cancel culture anyone who signed
that letter showed that they are stupid
MH did not read it did not think ahead
do you want to hire someone to your
company who blindly marches with morons
or do you want to hire someone who's
like I read that letter and said no way
it's one of two options you're stupid or
you're evil and neither one of those are
someone I would want in my life in any
capacity definitely not someone I'm
giving money to or both or both most
likely both but you know but that's it
it's like Sarah s made it Sarah s makes
a joke and other people have made jokes
like okay keep your job I don't care and
then they explicitly defend
terrorism and it's like okay you know
you're bad people I don't want to be
around you yep what do you say let's
jump to this story from ABC News that's
what I say Trump criticized for calling
Hezbollah very smart as he talked of
potential risk to Israel the former
president also called Israel's defense
minister a jerk what I absolutely love
about the story is ABC News doesn't
actually give you the full picture Trump
did not just say Hezbollah was very
smart Trump said they attack me for
saying things like this when I point out
that you know hezb they're smart they
know what they're doing they're going to
attack from the North and then an
Israeli defense minister said I hope
they don't attack us from the north
because we're weak there so then
Hezbollah does because they're smart
right they're attacking Trump over this
now trying to make it seem like he's
anti-israel or something like that
intelligence doesn't make you good or
evil you can be evil and intelligent you
can be good and intelligent he said XI
jinping's intelligent he was right the
guy's not dumb he's smart not
necessarily good that's not a claim of
good or
so yes people can be very SM ites not
qualify morals there was some celebrity
that got canel like a couple years ago
maybe long a couple years ago for saying
that Hitler was smart he was right
that's not even arguable I Would S
consider him evil but he was definitely
had high absolutely evil right I mean to
even reach the position of power I mean
you got to give Trump intelligence
points just for reaching the point of
presidency alone and then you know being
a billionaire but look at this Michael
Tracy Nails it he says it's hilarious
when Republicans try to attack one
another for not standing with Israel
hard enough they all have the exact same
position so so uh so must desperately
latch onto trivial turns of phrase like
it means anything yeah I'm sure Trump is
a huge fan of Hezbollah it's also I want
to play the clip DeSantis waram says new
Trump Praises Hezbollah calling the Iran
back terror group very smart hours after
they attacked Israel but actually listen
to this and then two nights ago I read
all of Biden's security people can you
imagine National Defense people
and they said gee I hope Hezbollah
doesn't attack from the north because
that's the most vulnerable spot I said
wait a minute you know Hezbollah is very
smart they're all very smart the Press
doesn't like when they say you know I
said that presiden she of China 1.4
billion people he controls it with an
iron fist I said he's a very smart man
they killed me the next day I said he
was smart what am I going to say he
knows right but has they're very smart
and they have a National Defense
Minister or somebody saying I hope
Hezbollah doesn't attack us from the
north so the following morning they
attacked yeah they might not have been
doing it but if you listen to this jerk
you would attack from the north because
he said that's our weak spot this is why
Trump went this is it this is why the
people who listen to Trump end up
supporting him like Brandon str's story
where he was like I'm going to debunk
this narrative listen to Trump actually
talk and went oh like had this
transformation Trump is roasting the
media for insulting him for saying that
Hezbollah and shanping are smart it's
crazy to me that's plainly true yeah no
they're really dumb what you identifying
your enemy's strengths is the one of the
first steps in defeating your enemy yeah
mhm the simpler explanation here is it's
also just it's just verifying people and
they're not sending their best all over
again right the media is just taking
advantage of the fact that a lot of the
people who are watching it are going to
read the headline and they're not going
to actually listen to the clip through
the whole way and that's he does fall
into that trap he's been known to fall
in that trap but the people that are
going to look at this and take that as
an own already are looking to hate him
well I'm wonder I'm wondering I don't
know much about the Hezbollah attack in
the north is this did the Israelis set
them up did they create an area of the
north that they that they said was weak
in order to draw Hezbollah in and so
that they could get them where they want
them and maybe Hezbollah is not as smart
as he thinks they are I know nothing
about it I'm wondering cuz why would the
Israeli defense minister announced their
weakness out loud well I mean we saw
that even in in the war on terror we saw
people like on like openly saying like
this is the next troop movement and
stuff like that and people were who were
obviously watching CNN in Afghanistan
were like oh okay well now we know where
to go now we know where to defend Etc
it's just like it's just like a huge
it's a huge uh operational uh misguiding
or not what's the word I'm trying to
think of the word here hubis uh not
hubish but just like it's like why would
you do that it's just like it's a
mistake you know to say that like to
literally tell people you're weak
they're probably going to watch your
news media and figure it out someone's
going to be watching and that's like
that's the mistake they made I don't
know it's I don't know if they actually
go to them into it saying I know very
little about the Hezbollah moves in the
north but if they've got Hezbollah out
of position right now you know that
might not be a bad thing for them I mean
I will say I don't know much about that
situation either however watching that
first of all makes me appreciate how
funny just the way he talks is and I
always know he's gaining more power and
sort of like on his way back up when he
starts getting more unhinged in his
speech cuz he's really funny and that
you just see can see it but also during
in the time we're in right now with
everything going on that peace time that
we took for granted or maybe not us but
a lot of people took for granted during
his presidency it's it's looking a lot
sweeter to have again hopefully you know
it makes me more Pro Trump than I'm not
going to say ever but you know it it's
gotten so bad under Joe Biden that
people are begging for Trump trump back
it's kind of funny yeah yeah first time
I ever in my life have considered voting
for Donald Trump was today it's because
I don't see another War Commander that
we have running for president right now
right true Jo Joe Rogan said something
similar if it's Biden or Trump he would
vote for Trump over I would take Viv I
just feel like where what's his presence
I don't know is he actually challenging
Donald Trump I I but I mean I I trust
Viv face to face I like where his head's
at where his spirits at but Don's got
the experience of working in the white
house for four years and I feel it's
we're a very desperate situation not
just that Donald Trump negotiated
internationally for decades yeah and we
what he was doing goes back to my belief
that we need the Russians as allies if
we're gonna hold the line and he has
that you know going back to what I kind
of said that like slight unhinged thing
that's actually a very positive thing
like we were kind of saying before we
went on air it's like why wouldn't you
want the world to be ever so slightly
afraid of messing with our guy I mean
that's just common sense when Trump said
there's that phone call that got
released or whatever where Trump is like
you know I told Vladimir Putin and shim
ping that if they invaded I would nuke
them and he maybe he didn't believe me
but maybe 5% it's good enough something
like that it was but that's real like
that's actually kind of how the world
works UK will nuke you it's like uh for
real speak softly and carry a big stick
is Teddy Roosevelt but the big stick
isn't just the nuclear armaments that we
have it's the ability to utilize them
that's the big sck Biden doesn't seem to
have that people aren't afraid of that
guy no and that 5% margin that you just
said it's like that's enough that's
enough to not want to do it she like
calls Vladimir and he's like I just got
off the phone with Trump and Vladimir is
like yeah me too and he's like did he
say he was going to Nuke you he did do
you believe him I don't know man let's
chill out better to not risk it yeah
he's going to Nuke you that's crazy
that's funny did he get on the phone a
lot with Putin well I don't I don't I
don't know to what extent like it
actually was conveyed I am quite worried
at the idea of of a of a US president
threatening to Nuke another Nation but
the general idea is peace through
strength right there's there was no
conflict there were no new Wars in fact
wars were winding down and Trump was
trying to get our troops out of the
Middle East and working on peace
agreements the proof is in the pudding
no matter how people want to portray his
efficacy it's like we did just have one
state of being which was there wasn't
anything like that's going down it would
also be interesting to like for people
who might be more open to it now who
just either didn't care didn't pay
attention but to look into like the the
negotiations between like him and other
countries or the Abraham Accords to look
at what happened or maybe now they look
at him going into North Korea with a new
you know in a new light because they're
seem volatile overseas relations
actually are uh that might actually play
in his favor I'm concerned if uh a
global war goes hot which I mean it's
already heating up but uh that remember
World War I the Bolshevik Revolution
immediately after the war shortly after
the War Began Communist Revolution in
Russia so that that would happen in the
United States that the pro Palestine all
these marches and stuff that there would
be an armed Uprising in the United
States to take control of the country to
lead it to protect Palestine over Israel
and then I could see us having the
internal struggle not even being able to
help Israel cuz we're dealing with our
own crap so I think if we can get ahead
of it prepare for it now and prevent it
it's the other way around the the the
far left is being run over the Kohls for
for supporting Terror I I'm glad that's
it's the difference is they didn't have
the internet in 2014 or 1914 so they
didn't see it coming but we see it
coming we see this crazy manipulative
Underdog always first strategy and it's
not working and the government doesn't
like it either that's the benefit of it
is the the always first yeah it's like
Underdog always make the underdog win oh
right right right Marxism you're right
and then lie about who the underdog
really is right yeah yeah yep it's them
when they're when they're losing and
need to win mhm it's their friends when
their friends are losing and need to win
if they're winning they're still The
Underdogs they're still losing and
there's always more work to be done
there
is yeah but I see what you mean by that
but the thing about 1917 is that they
literally left the war they left the
world war cuz they were fighting the war
since the beginning I think and then
they had a civil war from that um but
but yeah I I can see where the you're
where you're trying these like the
analogy towards but uh I don't know also
with what's going on here right it's
like a lot of this this is college kids
that are LARPing as revolutionaries and
it's not really the same thing I really
do believe in a lot of respects that it
uh things don't get bad as like things
don't get worse until food starts
rationing and people can't feed their
families and then you have a lot more to
worry about the French thing is
interesting did you see the French the
revolts in France they were protesting
Republic yeah they were protesting Pro
Palestine and and then the government
said that's illegal and then they
started protesting that the government
made their protest illegal and then
things are getting hot literally no
reverse that happened within like two
days tomorrow is the global Jihad day
and there's all these protests all over
the world in support of Hamas it's it's
crazy what advice is just you know if
you're armed you know stay safe stay
armed stay in your house go don't I
don't live in a city we we're out in the
middle of nowhere so I'm good like some
people like just go about your business
don't let Terror stop you other everyone
look everyone uh here is fine except for
Blair Blair's on a plane tomorrow right
love the day y'all books me but um but
real question half kidding mostly
serious am I crazy for kind of wanting
to drive home no no stay another day
yeah hang out yeah we'll just move I
feel like I'll think about it I put
flight off tomorrow as well because I
don't want to feel like I'm being
hisonic about something but it's also
like I mean it's the Friday the 13th
it's just crazy we'll just we we'd love
to have you we'll extend your flight and
then tomorrow we play poker I'll think
about it I'll think about it don't don't
travel on Friday the 13th Jihad yeah in
the solar eclipse and that red heer
thing like what something happens and
they're like look you had all the
warnings in the world like it's
something about the red heer that
particularly is like I don't know
regarding the red heer that's like the
the move for the the like the extremist
religious sect of is the Israeli
government that they want to prop bring
about the Third Temple and instantiate
the the second coming I I'm concerned
that if they if they try and force it
through the first coming right like the
Messiah will finally come for real but
but Christians uh have like Christians
and Jews believe the same thing about
the red heer don't they it's just that
for for Christians the second coming and
for Jews it's the first coming yes I
don't know I'm not a religious scholar I
was just reading reading some articles
about it yeah but is isn't like if the
Messiah comes isn't that he doesn't just
stay and chill and like live with us
right that's the end of the world right
the Messiah leads an army and take
conquers the world and then brings World
Peace but is that Christian or is that
Jewish I don't know they don't say So
within Judaism the Messiah has not come
yet so be the first coming and I don't
think in that in that worldview that
it's the end of the world within
christiandom if the if the second coming
occurs then yes it does mean the end of
the world in Catholicism particularly
it's different in different sects of
Christianity too so I guess we'll see
who's right but what is it in Mormonism
because this would be the third coming
yeah uh I really yeah be second or third
yeah third coming I guess you're right
yeah because in uh I I I could be wrong
but Mormons believe that Jesus came like
a thousand years later to the North
America or something like that I don't
if years later yeah I don't know if it
was a thousand years later when he was
currently on Earth that he traveled
across the ocean and I don't know I know
my concern is that when realism kicks in
if you try and force this thing through
military and execution that it's going
to it's going to backfire like the
Israelis think that they're going to do
some good by doing this I have a fear
that it's going to backfire on them so
that's the real side of it I just I
don't think it's can be forced with
military I don't know
I I hate to see because it was in a book
that we going to just kill all these
people and and force in front of the
world with video with internet video
like you think you can accomplish
accommodate War atrocities with internet
video it's not the right time for that
cuz if you really believe it's a
prophecy and supposed to happen it's
going to happen whether you push it or
not right so just chill please everyone
chill yeah she's like I got a plane to
catch tomorrow would you guys CH
honestly I have a life to live you like
20 songs I haven't recorded yet I'm like
every time I go to play video games now
I'm like I am wasting valuable time it's
which is good what's that and you're
running out I know that's what it feels
like like I just spent the last two
years playing video games at night not
worrying like uh I can't wait for
tomorrow what the hell is tomorrow like
this is now this is it this is time time
is not real it is always right now and
it's like no time to wait I mean there's
this create what you want to create
right now now is the time yeah and
there's been several incidents in the
past few years that we should just
learned that and kept knowing that right
but it comes into more clarity during
times like this where like half joking
but half serious on a plane and I'm kind
of scared about it you know it's like it
comes into clearer view that reality I
had a I was in a band called the Panic
for a long time and I didn't really want
to be in the band but it was falling
apart I was getting high beforehand I
wasn't practicing properly and
eventually they were like all right Ian
you're out of the band I was like No And
then I like gave it everything and
they're like it's too late and I was out
of the band was the band called Blind
Melon it was called the Panic yes it was
BL Blind Melon actually I was the
original bro watch the music video for
Blind Melon with no rain great s just
four Ian but the lesson I learned Is For
Real that'd be a good band name I'm not
kidding the lesson I learned is don't
wait till the last minute to give it
everything give it everything right now
go hard now yeah true bro I swear like
this video it's just like Ian modeled
his whole life off of these guys this
has changed my life in 199 the little
girl in the bumble Bumblebee costume
where's the guy at look at this guy oh
yeah bro that's like that's himn him
it's literally just like Ian wanted to
be him oh man look at those
this very e encoded good song
though we're we're trying to bring a
little levity uh to your lives before
the day of jihad you know a little
hippie Justice I mean I got be honest I
feel like nothing's going to happen
that's the point it's Terror they want
you to be afraid exactly right exactly
they want people to like lay low not
work disrupt the economy yep disrupt the
economy but what do you do man because
there's crazy people who are like even
if even if you think that was their
intention some crazy person is going to
do something it takes one crazy person I
saw Jack bobic tweeted out a video of
like a car doing donuts in the middle of
the freeway in New York did you see that
I don't know if it was Rel if it was
related I don't if they were screaming
Palestine or something but they were it
was it blocked traffic in New York that
was today I think part of it is like it
feels like lately the world is crazy
every day so for there to be a specific
day where it's supposed to get more
crazy more crazy it's like okay it's
also the internet though it's just the
access to all of the all of the crazy
things that happen at your are now at
your fingertips and in your pocket all
time back in the day you would have had
to watch like you know maybe they
include a couple stories like that at
the end of the news if you watch the
news when you were younger not everyone
did now you're not getting it in the
form of like some stuffy dude in a in a
suit telling it to you it's in your
pocket and you're scrolling through and
you're algorithmically being programmed
to see how how crazy the world is every
single day and that's hard on anyone's
brain and that violence you know it's
like I was thinking about like the day
everything kind of started I was flying
home from Vegas and I saw the imagery of
like people just murdered in the streets
there was like a I think it was the
image of you know the elderly people
outside the bus stop just and I cried in
the car and I was actually shocked that
I cried and then I was shocked that I
was shocked about it because I'm like
how is it shocking that I'm crying when
I'm seeing this am I that desensitized
that it's rare for me to cry when I see
a scene like that and that's society as
a whole you know it's like we are way
too desensitized to seeing just things
that you not meant to see it in the past
you would have had to go to like
Psychotherapy to cope with the fact that
you saw it hyper hyper normalization
yeah I kind of been keeping off uh
looking at the videos I'm wondering
today should I expose myself to some of
these traumatic deaths in in I do you
you you who have been watching it oh I
look at all the videos I watch them all
I saw one of a dog getting shot did you
see that that was tough I I don't care
to see that I mean my God I watch it all
uh my view is I I not it's not not for
everybody
but do you know what the real world is
or do you just live in the safety bubble
of the United States I feel like I can't
communicate properly with the people
that have been exposed to it unless I
expose myself to it yeah and I I my view
has always been since I was uh uh like I
I remember there was a viral video of
three dudes murdering a guy in in Europe
that was on like live leak and oh yeah
that one and I was like I'm gonna watch
it because this is what this is this
this evil exists and I I I feel there's
a lot of people like I don't want to
watch it I don't want to watch it and
that to me kind of felt like please
please let me stay under the covers the
monsters are outside whereas I'm like
you're better off like this this is
imagine this little kids hide under the
covers because they're scared of a
monster or something right like that's
the worst thing you can do because now
you can't see the threat and if there is
a monster it's coming for you yeah that
kid has no situational awareness exactly
exactly so my attitude is like you
should understand these things you know
you watch these videos you might get an
understanding you watch videos of War in
conflict and then if it ever comes up
you will understand it you in in the one
in one 100 million chance you find
yourself in a War or conflict and you've
watched these videos you might have a
slight bit of information or
understanding that someone else wouldn't
that could help you survive yeah yeah
and I can even identify that Within
Myself the fact that sometimes I do
really like I'm not going on Twitter
today because I don't want to see the
extent of it that is exactly what you're
saying that's actually the wrong thing
to do I just think some people are like
built differently like it'll affect in a
crazy way and some it's not like as
worth it but but you're right and be
weary of who's posting it because the
visceral reaction you will have to these
videos will be used to manipulate you C
whatever context it's put up because if
it if it goes up and it says this is an
Israeli settler and you're like ah you
get all this rage and then you find out
later it was like a a Sudanese dude or
something and you're like what in the
hell is from like two years ago but your
emotions have already fried and you're
like built these new neural Pathways
well look at look at the Covington kid
story mhm MH everyone even conservatives
were messaging me being like did you see
what this kid did and I'm like what did
he do and they're like look at the video
and I'm like I have no idea what's
happening in this video like two there's
a kid smiling in front of a guy who's
banging a drum right and they're like
yeah but he like got in his face I'm
like I don't see that in the video where
did that happen and they're like well
I'm like wait what that's a great
example of how twisted things were a
couple years ago even more so than now
in terms of that stuff where it's like
you're watching something and you're not
seeing it but you feel like you have to
agree that it's something bad happening
when it's a kid just sitting there I
don't there were a bunch of tweets like
Piers Morgan tweeted this thing where
he's like you know oh people are
debating they're asking were babies
beheaded why are why we used to be
outraged that kids were killed and what
what these people tried tried doing I
just get pissed off when you do this
they were trying to change the argument
to is this claim true and they made the
argument if you question it you don't
care that children died and I'm like
nobody said that and in fact the fact
that Pierce Morgan did say it he's a
scumbag for saying it and I will not be
manipulated by you you just pissed me
off we're allowed to say killing kids is
wrong and recognize they killed kids
while still being like we'd like
evidence there guy who like tweeted like
he's like like we don't need evidence
like that was just an actual tweet from
evidence isn't necessary I'm like lindsy
on on I think it was was it was CNN said
bomb Iran and they were like just to
clarify even with no evidence he's like
yeah
and then was this is crazy was asked so
you know the US would be spread very
thin he's like my dad fought in Japan my
uncle fought in Germany he was literally
invoking World War II to justify war
with Iran without evidence right now
yeah homeboy's calling for World War I
dude these people are evil John McCain
is just rolling over in his grave right
now just pissed rolling just he's just
pumped he's wish he could get out he's
not he's not rolling he's banging trying
to get out he's like I can't believe I
missed this one like round two let's go
round
just angry like cuz then Megan McCain
said something and they're like just
like Daddy said right like that's that's
how it is it's the anti-war protesters
spinning in their graves you know yeah I
don't I I I don't I I don't know
reference at which so many people that
again like we're saying have no concept
of what it actually is and are people
that are sometimes like me on those days
where you don't look right it's like the
ease at which people land on yeah go in
there let's fight it's like people get
that too what do you think uh George
Washington and Ben Franklin would say oh
I mean I don't know wait George George
Washington they were here
like Washington was an oror he was a
general he was a pretty good speaker too
but he was he was in congress with
everybody not he would say something
though I think how would they feel about
this CU obviously the Baler declaration
is real the British set up the Mandate
for Palestine over there after World War
I like it we're not are you say there
was no Palestine before that uh it
wasn't I don't I know if what it was
called but it was like uh it was Ottoman
for a while and then I think they took
it from the Ottomans after World War I
when the Ottoman Empire blew apart they
got rid of the Ottoman Empire but it has
just changed hands so much but it's like
obviously the United States has been
involved with the formation of Israel in
1948 like what do we do George like what
do we do you guys because they were
considered terrorists too George
Washington King George called him
terrorists yep right I mean well I don't
think he used the word terrorist the
king I think he literally did actually
uh did he cuz terrorism comes from the
French Revolution which was after the
American Revolution see there is that
ter it's like it say one man's terrorist
is another man's freedom fighter and
that something that's going around yes
and I would love to get the perspective
of the guys that were called terrorists
fighting for their freedom from an
oppressive oppressive Tyrant because
that's what they claim the Palestinians
are right now but yeah I think it was
the French Revolution where the word
terrorism comes from which was after the
American reevolution it's like a whole
period of time but there the main ones
after yeah all right let's go to super
chats if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button sub
subscribe to this channel share the show
if you like it and head over to
timcast.net
from Jackson hle claiming that Ben
Shapiro's images of the babies in Israel
are AI generated and uh we're going to
go through this and break it down
because I actually did a quick analysis
myself I will not say that it is
definitive they are AI generated but
this AI uh uh uh uh what's the word an
AI detect there you go yeah detection
algorithm claims it is but these things
could be wrong the Israeli government
put out several photos and one of these
photos has been run through the AI uh um
detector detection unit detection unit
as uh as a but we'll talk about that
we'll talk about that in the members
only show and the reason for it is their
graphic images we're going to keep this
one it's not it's not family friendly
and it'll be on the members show but uh
let's read cultural abduction says Tim
you're making fun of Ian now but when
Palestine does become the 51st state
we'll see who's laughing then keep it
real Ian but hope everyone stays safe
tomorrow I'm honestly on edge dude when
I read that story it was like the other
day I actually got like a sinking
feeling I'm like what story the Hamas
just calling for a global a global Jihad
on Friday yeah and you're just like and
it's Friday the 13th I know with with
the ring of fire eclipse happening the
next day like couldn't wait till
Saturday the red half for last month
yeah 51st state but we can't make them
do it it has to be a petition from
Palestine weird nug says saw a video of
Palestinian children talking about how
they wanted to stab and run over Jews
don't know how I feel about it yes it's
a video from uh Gaza I believe it's Gaza
and they're asking children coming out
of school like what do they teach you
and the children are like that you know
they Israel is bad they're our enemies
and we have to win and we're going to
win and blah blah blah blah
blah all right what do we have here what
do we have
here what is this Shane H Wilder says
with graham chomping at the bit for War
I have been contemplating the song
Patriots Dream by Gordon Lightfoot about
Patriots who go to fight while the old
man in the hill Smiles a wicked smile
and he sends them off to die oof oof
yeah
Christina paaon says I love you Blair
love you
Christina U-Haul says why you terminate
my producers account after restreaming
last Friday at Miami not everyone can
afford a pay wall in biomics oh I I I
loved this Super Chat that came earlier
so for those that aren't aware we did a
special event that cost us hundreds of
thousands of dollars to to put on in
Miami and we sold tickets to it we also
for a variety of reasons put it on the
website as a members only show which I
explicitly stated like two weeks before
that we were doing this for several
reasons one because people in the
audience can yell things and we don't
want to have to be controlled like you
know get it get the whole show taken off
YouTube because people yell things so
we're like look it's just better for a
lot of reason to do it on our web on the
website as members only and we need to
do things that drive memberships we need
to literally create special uh programs
events that make it worth being a member
now here's the thing we just about broke
even in fact I think it's fair to say we
arguably did not break even but we're
we're just about there a little bit of
the merch maybe after spending a year on
working on this event and you know
hundreds of thousands of
we we maybe will come out with like a
couple Grand which we then have to put
right back in if we want to do more
events and this
dude as a member screen grabbed the show
and broadcast it for free on YouTube
basically spiking our effort and we're
wondering why we did not have a better
turnout and why we the member Drive
didn't work as well and it's a
substantial sum of money lost and to say
that people couldn't afford the 10 bucks
just to watch it on the website bro fine
whatever man but all we did was that
when the Show wrapped and we got word
that someone had broadcast the whole
thing out we just we we did a copyright
takedown saying you can't do this that's
it that's all we did as you should have
if you're a member and you violate the
terms like that you're going to lose
your membership yep well I mean it was
just my call it's so brutal because we
can barely do these events and it hurts
because if someone's poor and they want
access but the rules are you cannot get
take it and steal it sorry man none of
our speakers got paid and these are
speakers who normally get paid because
they willing to do that for us cuz
they're good people uh I worked two
extra weekends and didn't get paid so
you know even to say that it was Break
Even is only me I think being nice
because if someone else tried getting me
to come to an event and to spend a week
in another city and two extra weekends
of work insanely expensive for me to
want to do that it's it's it's it was a
I'll just say this the amount of stress
traveling doing the show for a week
somewhere else A lot happened behind the
scenes security-wise and it is difficult
and the goal is
cural events and then we're it's
goodable to a member we want to spend
that money it it is stressful for me
because I'm like but we're going to get
a lot of new members out of this and
we're going to create something
memorable and we're going to sell this
unique merch and then there's some dude
being like screw your efforts screw all
your hard work screw all the stress you
went through we're stealing this and
giving it to everybody for free that way
you can never do it again the end result
of this is the dude broadcast it for
free to everybody we're like it makes it
difficult for us to to do it again if I
have to go and say hey guys we are not
going to break even on this like who's
going to want to do it it's just me
basically just losing money and it's
unsustainable and then eventually run
out and then there's no more events so
that that one particularly pissed me off
and as someone who witnessed just on a
very it was easy for me to come to the
Aus one you did but I witnessed how much
stress you and the entire team was under
so all I did was have to walk into the
dressing room and say Hi and then go on
stage but I I saw how much stress you
guys were all under and it's like yeah
you deserve to be paid for that you know
what's not even about deserving to be to
be paid it's that I want to do events we
want to do more events if we don't make
money the events stop happening right
because like so the tickets were 175
bucks after tax and everything $200 why
otherwise we don't break even and if we
don't break even it's basically just
losing money and so in a lot of ways
like the Austin event I think we lost
like I I don't know the number like 20
or $30,000 we lost not Sur to do that
event we lost to that event because
we're like building these cultural
events and doing this is good it's
something we should do and then
fortunately Public Square sponsored this
event which is the only reason we
actually made it out on top and can do
another one so Public Square those guys
are awesome true and then after the show
we find out that 13,000 people watched
live a free version of it just ripping
us off completely and spiking our
efforts lame yeah it was so brutal dude
like getting punched in the stomach and
being like all that all that nightmare
of working 48 hours straight with no
sleep gone because some dude was like I
don't want to spend $10 yeah man I want
to shout out to Mosaic the company that
did the AV I I don't you know better
than I do Serge but these guys did a
spectacular job took a lot of the stress
off the team and it was really great
working with them yeah they looked so
good thanks man appreciate it but uh
yeah to the guys producer come on bro
what the hell it's like it's crazy to me
that people are like no Tim you should
work for free you should give us free
stuff because we can't afford it okay
Tim remember your Robin Hood roots no
it's just like give us taxes then that
was the last event if that's the
attitude people have I am not I'm not
I'm not going to lose another 30 grand
not not the night of if you're going to
restream it maybe we could consider
putting it up later for the public it
went up right away on iTunes and Spotify
it's up on iTunes Spotify right yeah
okay there you go yeah it's all up but
it's like we we're we're we're we're
trying to like survive we're trying to
build a company we're trying to win a
culture where we're trying to do more
and there are people who are like I
deserve it for free you you should work
for free I'm like that's just the
craziest thing yeah hi Callie yeah right
that's the it's just so crazy to me it's
like dude we we bar we we we we we if I
were to build my hours for the event the
event is negative heavily negative yeah
say love you say love you let's read
some more Super
chats show base though says every Marine
I know including myself is armed to the
teeth and looking forward to delivering
America to these peopleo
yikes Glory B2 God says a group of
cartel members have called for a purge
if Hamas is being led by the CCP this
could mean that China is using proxy
groups Target American civilians may God
have mercy on your souls that is one of
the stories that's come out that um
China is trying to draw the us into war
on four fronts so that when they take
Taiwan we can't do anything about it
spread us thin
yeah the bonus hole says Commander Biden
for Speaker of the House bacon Greece IV
drips for Hamas yikes that's a is that
the Biden's dog the dog he's going to
bite every he named his dog Commander
because we didn't have a commander in
the white house we needed one yes and
then he bit like 12 people yeah
yeah Alan shower shower says so with
Poo's vids today can Max come back and
explain accidental targets of
opportunity that musical failure Phil
leonti was correct everybody on our show
today was calling him the musical
failure oh yeah he on show today they're
like like all the super chats were like
oh it's musical failure filon I didn't
get the context of that super chat but I
would love to have Max back on anytime
uh poob has been posting a bunch of
videos like showing of collateral of
like showing what Hamas is doing there's
a video this is one of the videos I've
referenced they're trying to storm a
kabut which has got permitter fencing so
they hide in the bushes until civilians
pull up run up and execute the civilians
and you can watch the full video in full
detail and then they the the car as soon
as the car opens the gate they kill
everyone inside of it and then run
inside it's it's nuts man it is so
sick yeah it's crazy God Kos so says
please look up Samir Khan in car with
alaki CIA could not authorize a Kill
Order just to waited until they were
together and called it collateral damage
wow wow evil crazy
man all right what do we have Jacob
Holly says Tim and crew I might not
always agree with you or your guests but
I sincerely will be praying and hoping
for your safety be safe look out for
your friends and family keep on the
spiritual journey Ian I've been praying
with my pastor for you thank you very
much uh look for me later on Twitter
probably closer to midnight I'll you
know that is it's all that psychic
energy is being directed right at you
and you're absorbing true you'll start
to dream about me too but it's not no
I'm talk like people need to stop
praying Ian's getting ripped and I saw
him levitating and his eyes were glowing
earlier you'll notice that when you
watch someone a lot it's kind of like a
form of worship like if you have someone
on the internet that you like to watch
and listen to a video blogger and then
you'll start to they might appear in
your dreams and give you wisdom and
things like that just be careful with
cult worship yeah
true Clayton Webb says will y'all make
freeze-dried instant coffee want to put
it in my gear um that's actually a good
idea I'm not you know on the surface
it's like why would we do that but in
terms of people who are going camping or
doing survival stuff then you definitely
want something like that so I don't know
if we have the means just yet but we're
working on a bunch of stuff we're
working on uh supplements but uh only a
few I'm not a big fan of like doing the
you know Super Brain formula weird
herbal garbage I don't do any of that
stuff but protein powder and mctt the
reason why we're considering doing it is
because I don't like what's on the
market yeah I will say Joo milk is the
best protein powder I've ever had and so
that solves a lot of my my like so I
don't know if I need to make a protein
powder but uh I want an MCT protein
blend so high fat content mix true then
you just add water it's like a milkshake
that's what I'm talking about like a
timat
M I don't know about
that are fun though like M are fun once
a year with your friends you crack One
open and see what prize like what you
get oh what I got I got a weird thing of
raspberry jam or something the videos do
well when people do videos on YouTube of
those too but I mean it's just you know
I think you'll die you ever see the
video of the guy eating like a 100y old
MREs from Civil War he's
like that I that's like what what they
don't know is when people come out here
back in back when in the early days of
Tim C when you'd come out here Tim would
then get new people here to try MREs
they're all downstairs mean we have a
bunch but I'm saying but back then like
it was like when new people would come
in when there like more people were
being hired Tim's like Hey try this m
that's because the Mr had just come and
they're in a big box and I'm like have
you ever had an M we got one right here
he's like watching if you're sweating or
not when you're eating it bro they have
iron shavings and you pour water in it
and oxidizes and heats up and that's how
you cook the food yeah wow yeah M are
fun it's like it's like bring your kids
out in the backyard and do a little fake
fake fake camping trip with 10 and have
a little M or something I actually have
a bunch of the like the Entre I ordered
the Entre I would eat them before the
show some of them are really good and
some of them are just should should be
crimes yes the for the most part the
ravioli's fine yeah yeah it's D you know
what I mean the ravioli and the and
those are fine some of them not not so
much I think the pizza is not food but I
still liked it we had pizza Lunes
growing up you want an m at this one
I'll eat any want go run and grab one
real quick I yeah where are they do we
have any are they I don't know if
there's any I I didn't see any down
there last time I got a bunch but
they're just the I have just the Entre
oh you can see if there's one in the
store and I'll try it's uh when you go
and you turn left and it's on the shelf
on the left going to make me throw up or
no no no no it's just like it's it's
just it's
like it's like store when you go to the
store you get Hamburger Helper and stuff
it's just the prefab freeze dried and I
was going to say maybe get something
that will make me throw out better cont
but see I like them but that's cuz I eat
like trash so we'll eat them during the
members only we we'll crack open an M
that would be the members only get they
don't actually last that long I think
their their shelf life is like two years
yeah it's not that long yes but I but I
only got them because it was fun and
it's like let's we should we should do a
video where we crack open some Mr and
eat them yeah a lot of it's just like
not good you don't want to eat it it's
like a lot of sugar a lot of carbs yeah
yeah I can understand if you're in the
middle of like a combat zone you want to
just Jam some food in your gullet or
whatever but I I don't want to eat this
stuff
we'll grab some more what do we got
Bender the offender says I work and live
near a steel mill in Ohio if a foreign
power invaded the US would the
manufacturing plants be targeted for
bombing or do you think they would try
to strategically take the plants over
depends on what they're doing if it's an
invasion they take them over but they
would there would probably be some
degree of damage to them but people got
to understand this about war you need
resources for war yeah that's it you
can't just invade a country and then
shoot like you have to take control
mhm support your troops yep need supply
lines and
everything what have we
here uh what do we got let's grab a
Super Chat gunface says by these
people's logic shouldn't they be put out
to pasture since we live on Stolen Land
from the Native Americans exactly that's
that's the point a lot of people make
the far leftists will not give up their
own property nimm but wasn't it Native
Americans demand demanding back a c like
Vermont or something uh I think so some
some politician said something about it
they okay then give us land back right
now and they're like oh well actually
name a land that isn't stolen right and
maybe I'll take you seriously then if
you can actually and also it's so
humanist right these people are claiming
that Native Americans own the land the
deer and the Bears right the Wolves
right it was stolen from them not a
speciesist is that the word species
speci speci speci yeah that's actually a
thing people say no it's the vegans say
that right speci speciesist or specious
speci I think neglectful sausage says
even in the future called Star Trek the
people on all the space Stations of the
ecosocialist Federation worked literally
Non-Stop and owned
little that is true but you're referring
to the military like Starfleet was
effectively like the Navy so well of
course people there worked all the time
they're in military service but you know
everyone else on Earth had unlimited
food Star Trek didn't address a lot of
the issues that needed to address like I
would like to open up the Star Wars I'm
sorry Star Trek universe and then have
them explain how the Israel pal sign
conflict got resolved like you're in the
future oh those are not MREs those are
not MREs emergency food storage that is
not an M you grabbed the wrong what I
was handed uh who handed you that
Charles I know where they are I know
where some of them are what do they look
like are they white no they're brown
brown yeah they're brown they're brown
and on the bottom of the Shelf I'm going
take another look but these are
emergency food in case you are wondering
these are pretty good those are the sa
and these up here maybe we can show them
off every once in a while yeah we'll
show them off on the member show cuz we
got them creamy chicken flavored rice
these are actually really good yeah true
very delicious actually there was a
period where we started cracking open
too many of our emergency food buckets
because the food is legit good there's
like stragg off and we would use it as a
base and like cut steak and chicken into
it and put cheese and I'm just like
we're supposed to be saving this it's
Hamburger Helper like these bags that he
bought up they last for 25 years I'm
literally getting so hungry yeah he need
to bring something good up I swear to
God well the m is you're supposed to
just open and eat you know what I mean
right yeah there's like the peach
cobbler but it's I think it's we have
that down there I know where it is but I
can't leave cuz right now like a bag of
Goo yeah they taste so good yeah it does
it's probably H those corn are Victor M
says Tim you should play cursed cursed
Halo instead of balers Gate 3 what well
I've done like four run throughs of
balers Gate 3 already so I'm I'm
basically done with it now I'm just
looking at mods I don't know chiso is
but I've heard Starfield is too woke
nobody and like people are abandoning it
really yeah yeah don't know
not sure the big problem with balers
Gate 3 is that everyone in the game that
you can be like everyone is pansexual
and constantly trying to bang you to the
point where it's like I'm it's it's
really annoying and I'm just skipping
skip skip skip like dude it's
carlac okay for those that did you find
it okay he found one he found one
Charles rectified it let me see so what
what the actual like chicken chunks
white and cooked that was the last M
really the last one the last it was the
last one in the Box I found yeah no
there's a there's a bunch e there's like
there's like unop or half open on how do
I open this do I need a knife or
something no I just got to rip on the
top so I just bust it open and eat it
well no no no you open there a bunch of
little things and a bunch of little bags
and pack pouches and stuff there's
things you got to heat there's like
things to heat stuff up etc etc like
don't break a nail
yeah all right did you get it are you
opening from the wrong spot am I I
handed a certain oh yeah okay that was
my fault my
bad these things are super easy to open
you just tear it what are you doing I
saw an M out of the Ukraine I don't know
real but it was like a fish fish out of
a bag all right let's see hold hold it
up so the camera can see it so this is
what it looks like with the directions
the he they have a heating element and
stuff too um so this is chicken let's
see open another bag there's a oh
there's Reese's in there really yeah you
want to eat those if I I need to get
like a this
pen see it's secure cuz it's for when
you're in the battlefield you know it is
secure and I will say that but if I was
on a battlefield I don't know if I know
it it's kind of loud oh they do have
Reese's and it's not even like an off
brand it's original that's sick I'm
going to start with these what what are
the other ones what's that one trail mix
trail mix chicken chunks this is
definitely it's like
Saucy Saucy or like liquidy chicken
chunks moist tette okay I mean that can
come in handy you know what do you do
with is it mayonnaise or something what
do you do with chicken chunks do you
like cheese bread yeah they got crackers
so you put the chicken chunks on cheese
on crackers with cheese wait this is
looking like a whole Feast actually like
I really actually fine with this what'
you get tortillas my have everything are
you kidding I thought it was going to be
some like gnarly uh First Strike
energy bar going to need energy in that
Battlefield you know what is that one
orange powder orange drink rehydration
El extra light oh there you go so I
guess you put your chicken chunks on
your tortillas and put cheese on them
wait I I don't see the chicken chunks
though I it's that it's that gray bag
right there this okay okay so what
should I eat tell me what you eat think
eat the chicken you got open the
tortillas first eat the chicken chunks
with okay spoon tortillas there also
well no you put them on the tortilla
with cheese and you're making a chicken
quesadilla okay that sounds awful but I
bet it tastes good not the chicken
chunks and the cheese spray I could
literally go get one of the get one of
the spaghetti or something like that
might be more appetizing okay look it's
a whole Taco Bell moment yeah look
tortillas hey nice loving that and then
uh I think I was the only person in the
world that liked Taco
Lunchables was Taco Lunchables yeah oh
yeah that was a thing Taco lunchable oh
yeah that was a thing I remember those I
think before you were Bor yeah you it
come off it's like it's like we have
cans of chicken downstairs you crack
them open and you just eat them all
right I'm going to I'm going to fold it
with a little tortilla you got put
cheese on it I'm not a big cheese person
okay I'm going to try the
chicken
live react there you go I'm getting that
what is it tast it good I don't want to
be dramatic it's not great the tortilla
is f the chicken is it dry it's it's
tasting like not chicken you know is
there like hot sauce or something or
mayonnaise or something
pepper I mean it's not terrible but it's
not tiny after KCK tiny after kick bad
one what is that uh not great hot sauce
actually so you know what we're going to
do that we're going to try that hot
sauce oh careful that would be really
good probably this is going to explode
on me um some scissors you got any
scissors over there no not right here
let's uh we'll read some more Super
chats as this is going on Ryan the
eating War says Second Coming Jesus
comes back with a flaming sword to lead
an army oh yeah what's the Flaming sword
in the Bible I'm trying to figure it out
did they actually have blowtorches no no
it's flaming sword dude yeah literally
flaming sword what's it really a flaming
sword L it on fire right yeah but I kind
of want one of those T they oiled it up
and there was a bush that was on fire
that wasn't like degrading like there's
a lot of stuff in the Bible it's not
exactly like real but I think they
really mean a
flaming we'll do it after only I'll make
one the mukbang in the m just don't
destroy them all like that yeah I was
picturing dud with like little
blowtorches and then if you got close to
them they'd kick it on really hard and
the flame would shoot out and they'd
stab you with the flame I'm like oh yeah
flaming sword yeah crazy that's awesome
actually okay here's an uh legma says
some of the things said here mainly by
Ian so ridiculous so inaccurate allowed
to stand on their so pseudo merits with
no debunking would be the easiest
debunks in history it's disgusting
almost sacriligious millions of Minds
fed nonsense I still support timcast
well thank you for the super chat but
the reason why your your Super Chat was
sort of like lame is because there were
no specifics all you got to do is say
one of the things I said and why and
then we can have a talk about it that's
true you could have literally you could
Super Chat and just be like here's what
Ian is wrong about bo bo bo you know you
could do 10 different super chats at 10
bucks but uh I appreciate it a lad who
ate four dozen egg says 10 bucks is
expensive Tim I I understand that how
much did he pay to tell you that 10
bucks 10 bucks
right I I I understand anyone want
Reeses uh all right well I'm going to
wait till the after show normally I just
like to like we have we have we have
peanut butter cups Quest ones they have
like no sugar but there's Splenda in
them so I don't really want to eat them
I'm good now yeah
thanks let's let's see what we got poly
puree says there was never a Palestine
in human history Mark Twain the author
visited is the Israel region in 1856 and
said said that not a single person lived
in that region yeah the Jews began
rebuilding it several decades later yep
that's what I was saying the other day
on the show is that it's it was
basically Barren land and until the Jews
were actually there and making uh making
civilization then then people moved in
and now they're claiming as their
ancestral lands
H all right what do we have let's grab
some more cbass says Jews are still
looking for their Messiah which
Christians believe that is the
Antichrist and Christians believe Jesus
is the Messiah and is coming back to
save the Jews which would be the Second
Coming you the Christians think that the
second coming is the Antichrist or that
the Jewish first coming is the
Antichrist and that there will be a
second coming that's different than that
person in during the second coming there
will be an antichrist that comes and
leads people astray essentially um
that's not the same as the second coming
of the Messiah so before the second
coming occurs there will be an
antichrist it's part of the whole the
whole second but the Christian Second
Coming is the Jewish first coming it's
the same guy yes because the Jew that
Super Chat was wrong then the Jews do
not believe that there was a first
coming of the Messiah they're still wa
they're still in remember Jew Jesus was
Jewish they were waiting for the
Fulfillment of all the previous Prophecy
in the Torah and the talod ETC and then
they don't believe that that Jesus was
the Messiah whoa look at this what the
heck says shout out to Jefferson Spirits
a bar in Medford Oregon for getting shut
down by the
OLCC from 10123 to 111123 for a masking
violation back in 2020 wow dude wow
wow evil people dude that's like sick
and twisted Beyond yeah especially right
now my God Raymond g Stanley J says
cheese spread was the bestest of the
best I used to squirt that stuff out of
the it's that word spread that I don't
like just like the chicken chunks and
the cheese spread just call it chicken
just call it cheese it's weird to me I
don't Chicken Chunks I also don't trust
the tortillas cuz it's going to be like
brominated plastic cardboard that yeah
it's probably the wor I don't think you
were supposed to put the spread on the
on the chicken it goes on crackers I
think it goes on the crackers sauce goes
spread on the on the chicken just sounds
gross what it's a quesadilla it's I
literally feel like such a piece of
just sitting here
eating but you make a quad you know you
take the tortilla put the the chicken
and the cheese on it I think it's just
supposed to be the chicken and the hot
sauce I really do think they could have
done better like these MREs like there
could be better see you could make your
own that's what I'm saying Gourmet
people would buy it make your own we'll
get Andrew GRL on this one there you go
rip up in the bag and then slide out a
plate with like this perfect Chef
designed salad and you pull it out it's
perfectly preserved nothing rotted for
some reason that's kind of the thing
like you can't have good stuff all right
what do we got Janes says hey all love
the show question for Ian any more plans
to update your feed for subscribers on X
oh yeah but I don't know what to do
exactly and I always feel guilty keeping
anything from on behind a pay wall it's
just part of this weird charitable thing
I've got going but I would love to I
would love to I should do just something
every week but I don't want to do
something lame where you're like this is
what I get but it's like you're getting
nothing right now I always basically put
in my work I could just do my workouts I
mean they're not like spectacular it's
just me you know biceps shoulders quads
you deserve to make money off of what
you do and what you give to the world I
I don't think you should feel weird
about that actually sent it is a
communist thing the the idea that profit
is somehow something to be guilty of is
a weird communist idea profit is
literally like hey I just did some work
and I feel that I would like to trade
the work that I did for something in
exchange and then Communists are like
they want they want to abolish profit
this something the DSA says abolish
profit profit is just literally what you
are getting for yourself the the this is
crazy you spend 20 bucks on some wood
and some Nails you then do the work to
make a birdh house and then say $25 that
five bucks is so that you can buy food
and they're like no you shouldn't be
allowed to right so then how do you get
food you don't all right there's like
this thing going on where it's like if
you look at like the the the leftist
comics on like on like Kickstarter or
anything like that they'd always make
this point to like point out like this
is where all the money from the from
this Kickstarter is going to and they
would make perfectly clear that like
we're not taking anything home cuz they
understand that the people that are in
their audience would be absolutely
appalled at the idea of them making any
money whatsoever all right everybody if
you haven't already smash that like
button subscribe to this channel go to
timcast.net and we're going to be
talking about allegations that images
shared by Israel are fake and we'll
break down uh my assessment so far but
with nothing's definitive but we'll show
you and the photos are pretty graphic
that's why it's going to be members only
smash the like button you can follow the
show at timcast IRL you can follow me
personally at timcast Blair do you want
to shout anything out uh yeah my YouTube
channel youtube.com/ blairex or just
Google Blair white um and go watch the
crazy debate I was just in because
you're going to have a lot of
entertainment from it I debated a clown
a literal person dress as a clown look
it up it's it's but yeah not a not a
joke not a joke no it was a a clown yeah
yeah guys if you want to follow me you
can follow me at Brett dvic on Twix and
on Instagram and please go check out pop
culture crisis Monday through Friday 3m.
Eastern Standard Time that is noon
Pacific right here on YouTube come hang
out with us I'm Ian Crossland follow me
at Ian Crossland and hit me up on
Twitter later around midnight Eastern
Standard time I'm going to be going live
it might be before that could be a
little bit after that and uh we'll talk
we'll go deep lots of people I like
having people add about 12 people add
about probably 20 people people came up
and spoke yesterday or maybe 10 or 12 or
the so we'll keep doing that but for now
we're going to timcast.net
10 a.m. on the culture War Anne Coulter
and Desh Doza so this is going to be
awesome a very very in-depth
conversation deep in politics and I
think um with with guest this amazing
it's going to be a very very great
conversation I am honored to have them
here it's going to be a lot of fun sir
uh yeah and I am here uh as well I am
surge.com on Twix I'm going to keep
calling it Twix until we figure out what
the hell we're going to call the site
anymore uh I'm excited for tomorrow but
I'm not going to be here it'll be C do
in the show so yeah it be sweet all
right everybody we will see you all at
timcast.net
I